Moin Leute
Exzellent
Boah, ich bin noch viel zu geschwitzt, um das Headset aufzuziehen. Was mach ich denn da jetzt?
Ich leg das mal kurz vor mich
Und ich muss es eh umstöpseln. Ich muss es eh umstöpseln, warte mal kurz
Sonst hört sich das nämlich wieder so kacke an
Heckweight
Sekunde
So, jetzt viel besser, ne?
Leute, ich muss mal kurz den Kopf abputzen
Boah, ich bin immer noch übelst am schwitzen
Okay, Pogu, da bin ich wieder. Also
Ich muss gerade meine zweitägige Rennrunde absolvieren
Eigentlich war das jetzt ausnahmsweise mal nur den dritten Tag, weil gestern konnte ich nicht
Dafür bin ich gestern ein bisschen so rumgelaufen. Insgesamt glaube ich fast drei Stunden
Aber gestern hatte ich Wartungsarbeiten auf der Arbeit und musste immer mal wieder an den Rechner
Hier Leute, guckt mal, ich zeige euch mal was. Twitter
Ganz, ganz frisch hier
Oh, ge. Stripes, 50 Milliarden Jahre, danke, Pogu. Das ist extremly
Mindblown, genau. Schaut mal kurz hier
Alter, Twitter wird auch immer mehr pp-iger. Was ist das denn? Kann man das so anzeigen oder wie geht das jetzt?
Ja
So kann man das anzeigen
Wilde Igel, danke für den Sub. Splixer, danke Leute. Guck mal hier, neue Rekord heute morgen
Neue Rekord, bam
Fünf Kilometer. Ich meine, meine Strecke ist eigentlich 6,2
Aber ich habe einfach nach fünf gestoppt, weil ich konnte nicht mehr. Es war genug für mich
Fünf Kilometer
Fünf Minuten 45 pro Kilometer
Also ich hatte, laut meiner Watch, waren das eigentlich drei Rekorde auf der Strecke, nämlich
Ein Kilometer
Neue Bestzeit, fünf Minuten 33
Neun Minuten sieben für eine Meile und
28,51 für fünf Kilometer
Also so
Also so wie das teilweise umschrieben wird, nicht. Also ich meine, das längste was ich gerannt bin, bisher waren glaube ich
8,2 oder 8,3
Irgendwie so in dem Dreh
Und das bin ich recht langsam gelaufen
Dementsprechend war das, war das gar nicht jetzt so, dass ich mir laufend gedacht habe, oh jetzt muss da aber aufhören, sondern
es war eigentlich ganz
Okay, ja
Wie lange ich das jetzt mache
Kann ich dir sagen
Ich muss gucken, wann ich meine Uhr gekauft habe, sage ich euch, noch nicht so lang
Deswegen habe ich ja die Hoffnung, dass ich das demnächst auch
hinkriege, was ich mir so vorgenommen habe und zwar, wo habe ich denn meine, meine Uhr gekauft hier
So, also die Uhr habe ich am 2. August gekauft
Und ein bisschen, kurz danach habe ich angefangen mit Rennen
Die habe ich erst mal nur ein paar Tage so zum Kennenlernen gehabt, zum Aufzeichnen und so
und
Sagen wir einfach mal, kommt jetzt ja auf, auf ein, zwei Wochen nicht an, sagen wir mal, ich mache das zwei Monate ungefähr
Seit Anfang August, sagen wir mal zwei Monate, ruhen wir ein bisschen auf
Ja, sad girl
Also ungefähr zwei Monate, aber man muss dazu sagen
Ich bin ja vorher schon
Jetzt nicht Rennen gegangen, sondern seit ein paar Jahren
Laufe ich ja jeden Tag so, also wirklich laufen, so mit Stöckchen, so wie die Rentner, so mit Nordic Walking Stöcke
So eineinhalb, zwei Stunden
Aber halt nicht, nicht irgendwie super
super sportlich oder so
Dementsprechend so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen
Grundkondition und so hatte ich ja, weil da geht es ja auch Berge hoch
aber
Also ich muss echt sagen, also schneller kann ich nicht
Also ich könnte vielleicht, wenn es wirklich um Leben und Tod geht, wenn ich wüsste, okay, ich falle halt
Ich sterbe sonst sicher, könnte ich sicherlich noch ein paar Sekunden schneller
Weil ich muss ja da immer noch so 1,2 Kilometer heimlaufen danach, aber
Also viel schneller, ich bin, also hier bin ich, man sieht das ja auch, 165 im Durchschnitt, also da bin ich auch schon ziemlich im Arsch
Wusstet ihr, dass das so ziemlich
Nur, dass man das mal einordnen kann, der
der Marathon
Weltrekordhalter, der hat mal seine Garmin, äh nicht Garmin, äh wie heißt das, Strava Daten veröffentlicht und er hat
Ich glaube 168
Puls gehabt im Durchschnitt über einen Marathon
Also im Prinzip das gleiche wie ich, nur dass der halt irgendwie 42 Kilometer rennt und, und der ist
Ziemlich genau
Ja, ziemlich genau, doppelt so schnell
Doppelt so schnell wie ich
Und läuft das zwei Stunden über, über 42 Kilometer
Das ist so krass, ich konnte das vorher nie einschätzen, wie krass das ist, aber
Das ist, das ist echt
Unmenschlich, ja
Da muss ich mal überlegen
Der Typ läuft
Im Durchschnitt
42 Kilometer, schneller als ich
Volle Pulle vielleicht mal ein Kilometer schaffe
Das ist echt krass, Alter
Ja, Ruhrpuls wirklich fast der, ich hab mal
Vor ein paar Jahren, äh keine Geschichte, also wie nennt man das, so eine Reportage gelesen
Über einen ehemaligen Tour de France Profi
Der ist gestorben
Und ich glaube wegen Drogenüberdosis, hatte, hatte nichts mit Doping und so zu tun, zumindest
die haben
über den, also ein bisschen, haben einen Artikel über den geschrieben
und
Der hat erzählt, also Pantani, genau, ja, das war eines der, also einer der gedoptesten ever
Aber was ich, was ich halt super krass fand in der Erzählung, also in dieser, in dieser, in dieser Story
Der hat erzählt, in seinen Dopingzeiten
Musste, also in seinen Dopingzeiten hatte er irgendwie einen Ruhrpuls von 32 oder sowas, das ist so wirklich, das ist wirklich
Deadge, kurz vor Sarg, so und da hat er erzählt, der musste nachts
Nachdem er, nachdem er sich super krass gedopt hatte, der hatte, der hatte ein Pulsfrequenzmesser dran
Und wenn seine Herzfrequenz nachts
Irgendwie unter, keine Ahnung, 30 oder so oder 32 gefallen ist, dann musste er nachts aufstehen
und nachts ein bisschen rennen, weil
Sein Blut sonst so dickflüssig geworden wäre, dass er wahrscheinlich einen Herzinfarkt oder einen Schlaganfall oder irgendwas bekommen hätte
Also seine Ärzte haben zu ihm gesagt, hier, wenn du, wenn du, wenn dein Pulswarner angeht, musst du sofort aufstehen und dich bewegen
Also er musste mehrfach nachts raus und sich bewegen, weil sein Puls zu niedrig war, weil er sonst durch zu dickflüssiges Blut
Irgendwelche Blutgerinnsel bekommen hätte und Herzinfarkt Deadge
Also krass haben die sich gedopt damals, ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen, die haben eh schon, da gibt es, da gibt es Berichte aus der Zeit
Dass, dass, dass sie teilweise, wenn du das Blut
gesehen hast, dass das schon fast dickflüssig gewesen ist
So, so krass vollgepumpt mit roten Blutkörperchen war das
Also die, die waren wirklich, die waren wirklich bis, bis unters Kind zugespritzt mit irgendwas
Das müsst ihr, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, du musst, du wirst gewarnt nachts, dass du aufstehen musst, dass du keinen Herzinfarkt kriegst
Ne, du musst dir keine Gedanken machen, du musst dir keine Gedanken machen, weil du hast ja kein
Kein Epo oder irgendwelche anderen Substanzen genommen, dass du irgendwie, frag was weiß ich, wie viel mehr rote Blutkörperchen hast
in deinem Blut wie
normal
Wenn du einfach nur trainierst, ist das kein Problem, der Typ, der hat einen ultraniedrigen Ruhepuls, hat aber sich zugespritzt mit sonst was
Das ist ein kombinationales Problem, das ist schon heftig, oder? Also
Ja, finde ich auch, finde es echt nicht schlecht, oh ne, also Yoga habe ich wirklich gar keinen Bock, ich habe mir ein Fahrrad gekauft, Leute
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Tom da ist, der Tom hat ja gesagt, er kann ja mal bei sich im Shop gucken
Aber ich habe mir jetzt woanders ein Fahrrad gekauft, aber ich brauche noch ein paar Teile, da komme ich vielleicht zu euch
Ich habe, ich habe mir ein Fahrrad gekauft und zwar, das kommt am Montag an, ich habe mir ein
Einfach, weil die, weil das, weil das gut lieferbar war, ich habe mir so eins hier gekauft
Hallo
Im Blau, so eins habe ich mir gekauft
War ein Stück gute Kombination
Ich will hier auf Wegen fahren, ich will aber auch bei uns ein bisschen die, ich weiß, die Schweizer lachen sich wieder kaputt
Die Berge hochfahren, da sind halt viele so
auch mal ein bisschen Matsch, Waldweg oder
So Kiesel, Kieselsteinwege und sowas, dafür ist es eigentlich echt ganz gut
Und, was ich auch ganz gut finde, also ich wollte unbedingt
Wollte unbedingt eins mit einfacher Schaltung, nicht mit doppelter
Ja
Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice
Mal gucken
Montag kommt das an, Montag kommt das an, dann werde ich ein bisschen Fahrrad fahren, ich brauche noch, ich brauche noch einen Helm, muss ich mal gucken
Keine Automatik, ne, naja
Elektronische Schaltung aber
Kein E-Antrieb, ich will ja, ich will ja normal fahren
Ich brauche, ich brauche erst mal irgendeinen Helm, es ist unglaublich, wie viele Leute man auf dem Fahrrad sieht ohne Helm
Ja, also das war, das war auch der Grund, ich habe nämlich geguckt
Da habe ich mich auch gibaden lassen, da habe ich mich auch gibaden lassen, ich habe auch zuerst gedacht, ey
Nimmst ein Fahrrad mit zwei Scheiben, ich habe mir jetzt übrigens Fahrrad Fachsprache mir
angeguckt, der vordere, das vordere Zahnrad hier nennt sich Kettenplatt, habe ich mir sagen lassen in irgendeinem Fahrradforum, ja
Und das hintere, hintere nennt sich Kassette und auf der Kassette, diese Ringe sind Ritzel, es ist, es ist witzig, wie jedes
Gebiet irgendwelche komischen Fachbegriffe für irgendwas hat, ja
Zumindest
Ich habe am Anfang auch gedacht, ey, nimmst du eins mit zwei Zahnrädern vorne
Aber, wenn man sich das mal genauer anguckt, ist das eigentlich, je nachdem, was man machen will, eh
relativ unsinnig, wenn man sich die Übersetzung anguckt, also du hattest zum Beispiel
Das, das Gleiche, das Gleiche gibt es nämlich
Das Gleiche gibt es nämlich auch mit
Mit zweimal, so, und jetzt
Jetzt, jetzt kommt der Grund, warum es eigentlich relativ sinnlos ist, wenn man, wenn man nicht maximale Endgeschwindigkeit irgendwie auf der flachen Straße haben will
Also zumindest, das, wie ich mir das angelesen habe, ne, ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das irgendwie
ultimativ jetzt Ratschlag, aber guckt mal, hier unten steht, bei Ausstattung steht, was man für
Was man für Übersetzung hat, genau, hier, guckt mal, hier gibt es
Moment, das ist das Falsche, oder, was ich aufgemacht habe, ach hier, ne, hier, genau, guck
Hier gibt es vorne eins mit 48 Zähnen und noch ein kleines mit 31 Zähnen und hinten hat man 11 bis 34
So, das heißt, wenn man sich jetzt Gedanken drüber macht, wenn man den Berg hochkommt, kann man gucken, okay, was ist die kleinste Übersetzung, die man fahren kann
Das ist dann im Endeffekt
Zwo, äh, ist, ist, ist 31 vorne und 34 hinten, das sind dann quasi
31, 31 durch 34
Ey, what the fuck, war mal 31, habe ich richtig geguckt, ja
31 durch 34, das ist quasi eine Übersetzung, oder eigentlich ist, wenn du so willst, eine Untersetzung, was schon mit 0,911, so
Und jetzt kommt das mit einmal 11
Einmal 11 ist vorne
Einmal 11 ist vorne 40
Zähne und hinten 42, so, und jetzt passt mal auf
40, 42, das sind 0,95, das ist jetzt nicht der Riesenunterschied
Also, wenn du überhaupt nicht vorwärts kommst auf dem Berg, dann wird es dir das eine zum anderen auch nicht großartig bringen und mit zwei
Blättern vorne hast du halt
Auch ziemlich viele Gänge, die halt ähnlich sind, wenn du jetzt das kleine nimmst und das mittlere ist es wahrscheinlich ähnlich, wie wenn du das
Große nimmst und irgendwie zwei größer
Wo das, wo das tatsächlich mehr bringt, da war ich, da wurde ich nämlich auch
Gebated, ja, ich dachte, zwei vorne sind sinnvoll, wenn man nicht den Berg richtig hochkommt, das stimmt aber überhaupt nicht in dem Fall
Richtig sinnvoll sind die, wenn du auf der
geraden Straße volle Pulle fahren willst, weil dann kannst du 48, 11 fahren
und 48, 11 ist halt
Ist halt schneller als
40, 11, also das ist, das ist tatsächlich richtig sinnvoll, wenn man gerade aus schnell fahren will
Weniger, wenn man den Berg hochfahren will und das habe ich auch am Anfang falsch gedacht, ich dachte auch, ey, das bringt richtig was
Es bringt richtig was, wenn man, wenn man noch einen kleinen, aber ne, es ist eigentlich eher für
Massive schnell geradeaus, ja, das Ding habe ich, da habe ich das auch eingeben und was viel sinnvoller ist
was, was viel sinnvoller ist, wenn man
Tatsächlich nur eine Einfachschaltung hat, wenn man guckt, ob hier hinten noch, noch ein größeres draufpasst
Ja, Moment, es kommt darauf an, welche, welche
Sachen du montiert hast, in dem Fall, in dem Fall ist das
Minimal leichter, ja
Früher hatten die Leute, ja, ich hatte, ich hatte früher mal so ein
War nicht wirklich so, so ein Mountainbike-Verschnitt, ja
Da war ich, da war ich noch deutlich jünger, das hatte drei, das hatte so drei Blätter vorne
Bei den Pedalen und die eine war halt wirklich mini
Und da hattest du bestimmt noch eine krasse Übersetzung, aber
in dem Fall, in dem Fall macht, macht zwei und zu eins gar nicht viel aus, also ob
Zwei mal elf oder einmal elf, das macht richtig was aus, eigentlich nur im Flachen, wenn man geradeaus fahren will
Es gibt teilweise hinten
Oh, gerade da, da weiß ich nicht, es gibt teilweise hinten schon welche
So Kassetten, die haben bis 51, das ist dann noch mal größer
Einrad-Enjoyer, oh ja, mit dem Einrad den Berg hoch, das stelle ich mir auch lustig vor
Also das glaube ich nicht, dass wenn du ein offizielles
Da, wie nennt man das, so ein gesamtes Schaltwerk-Ding nimmst, dass dir da irgendwie die Kette runterspringt, nee
Das Einzige, wo du darauf achten musst, zumindest so wie ich das auf Reddit und in Foren gelesen habe
Wenn du vorne zwei Zahnräder hast, dass du bei manchen Kombinationen
Je nachdem, also wie schepp die Kette halt ist, also beispielsweise, wenn du jetzt
Ganz außen und hinten ganz innen bist, die Kette hat halt ein bisschen mehr Reibung
Und du verpulverst ein paar Watt, aber das ist nicht, und die Kette geht ein bisschen schneller kaputt, aber das ist jetzt nicht so als
explodiert dein Fahrrad
So, aber jetzt genug hier, Leute, was haben wir denn?
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack
Hier guck, alter Rekord, alter Rekord, neuer Rekord
Gehen wir mal auf ShitHub gucken
Was da so trendet, und ihr kennt mich ja, AI wird übersprungen
Oh nice
Godot, ich weiß, dass man das nicht so ausspricht
Godot trendet, woran das wohl liegt, Leute?
Was der Unity CEO wohl dazu sagen würde?
Okay, das klingt nach AI
Hast du schon was zu Mojo gesagt? Ja, letzte Woche habe ich was dazu gesagt, dass ich nicht einsehe, irgendeine Sprache
mir genauer an, also ich meine, es ist ja, es ist ja ein bisschen Python plus extra, aber warum ist das Ganze nicht Open Source?
Heutzutage sind alle nahezu ernstzunehmenden
Sprachen und Implementierung Open Source, also warum? Sogar Java, alter, also sprich
Warum soll ich irgendeine Closed-Source-Sprache nehmen? Das verstehe ich nicht
C-Sharp
Von einem der ehemaligen
Closed-Source und wie hat das Microsoft immer genannt?
Was, wie hieß diese Strategie von Microsoft früher immer?
Embrace Extinguish, nee
Embrace Extend Extinguish, ne?
Wo sie irgendwelche Technologien genommen haben, die es schon gab, mit irgendwelchem inkompatiblen Shit von ihnen erweitert haben, so dass das andere
ausgelöscht wurde, ja also mit einem der in der Vergangenheit zumindest
nervigsten
Unternehmenspraktiken, Läden überhaupt, sogar Microsoft hat das .NET Framework, beziehungsweise eigentlich, ja doch, mittlerweile darf man das ja wieder .NET
.NET nennen, nicht .NET Framework, ist sogar .NET Open Source
Was macht das für einen Unterschied, ob das Open Source ist? Naja, dass du zum Beispiel nachgucken kannst, dass keine Malware drin ist
Ich meine, ich gehe jetzt mal nicht von aus, dass es ist, aber
Keine Ahnung
Ich meine
Da kann prinzipiell alles drin sein
Das ist so das Erste, was mir einfällt
Oder dass, wenn du
Irgendwas hast, was sich ganz furchtbar komisch verhält, ja, stell dir vor, stell dir vor, du hast eine Liste
Du hast ein Array, 1, 2, 3, du sagst Sort
Und das braucht eine Millisekunde zum sortieren, wobei das ist schon sortiert, 3, 2
5, so, Sort, braucht eine Millisekunde, das ist übrigens in enorm, enorm langsam eine Millisekunde an der Stelle nochmal angemerkt, ja
Als wenn das wirklich eine Millisekunde brauchen würde, da müsste ich, da müsste ich eine Runde kacken, aber so und jetzt stell dir mal vor
Du sagst dann 1, 2, 3, du machst jetzt Sort und es dauert 100 Millisekunden
Was machst du dann?
Da denkst du jetzt, okay, hm
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, warum das so ist, aber ich kann mir die Implementierung von den, ihrer Sortfunktion gar nicht angucken
Sowas in der Richtung, also hauptsächlich, hauptsächlich würde ich mir tatsächlich Gedanken drum machen, ich weiß nicht, was
Letztendlich am Ende in meinem Programm landet, beziehungsweise nicht nur unbedingt in den Programmen landet, das kann man ja zur Not noch irgendwie durch genug
Analyse rauskriegen, sondern auch, was die ganzen Entwickler-Tools machen, was macht der Compiler, was landet bei mir auf dem Rechner, generell, ich find, es macht doch, guck mal, sogar Swift, ich glaub sogar, Swift
Guck mal, sogar Swift
Apple, ja, sogar Swift ist Open Source auf, auf GitHub
Wie gesagt, ich glaub es ja nicht, ich glaub es ja nicht, aber
Ich mein, warum macht man eine Sprache heute nicht einfach Open Source? Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum das so ist, ja
Ich weiß nicht, warum die nicht Open Source, hier guck, hört ihr euch
Ja
Exzellente Swift, das ist hässlich
Warum sieht in dem Fall Swift so hässlich aus?
Nvidia, ne, bei Nvidia, bei Nvidia ist ganz viel Zeug Close Source
Die haben einige Sachen, die haben einige Sachen auch auf GitHub
Aber sehr viel, sehr viel Close Source immer noch
Golem oder Heise Plus Abo? Ganz ehrlich, gar keins, ich hab, ich hatte mal ein Heise Plus Abo
Das habe ich mir gekauft, weil
Die haben noch, die haben ab und zu noch mal so, so Gehaltsumfragen und sowas und da wollte ich mal eine lesen, hab mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Guck dir das einfach mal an, mal gucken, wie Heise Plus ist
Und dann habe ich ein Heise Plus Abo abgeschlossen
Und hab festgestellt, es gibt keinen Knopf, um das zu kündigen, ja, ich weiß, es gibt theoretisch einen Knopf, das zu kündigen, aber das hat nicht funktioniert
Es gibt, das hat dann quasi nur I-Frame in I-Frame geladen, wenn man auf kündigen gedrückt hat
Und du konntest auch, ich krieg's nicht mal genau zusammen, vielleicht konntest du auch auf kündigen, vielleicht konntest du auch auf kündigen klicken
Dann hat's neu geladen, der Kündigen-Button, also er hat zumindest nicht gekündigt, ich musste dann an den Support von denen schreiben
Und sowas, richtig, richtig nervig
Und, und was auch, und was auch Abfang war, ich wollte, ich wollte einen Artikel lesen
halt Gehaltsentwicklung irgendwie, was, 1900, äh, nicht 1900, 2018 oder so
Und habe ich ein Heise Plus Abo abgeschlossen und hat es zwei oder drei Tage gedauert, bis ich überhaupt Plus-Zugang hatte
Ganz weird und dann habe ich versucht zu kündigen und dann hat der Kündigungs-Button nicht richtig funktioniert
Also ganz merkwürdig, alter, keine Ahnung
Das hol ich mir nicht mehr und Golem wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht, warum
Wie gesagt, ich glaub's, ich glaub es ja nicht, aber man, man weiß ja nie, guck mal
Jetzt ist, aber wisst ihr, was ich, was ich auch sehr merkwürdig finde? Die haben
Die haben halt ein GitHub-Repo und es hat 14.000 Sterne, die Frage ist nur, warum hat es 14.000 Sterne?
Hier ist nichts drin in diesem Repo, gut, man kann Issues reporten und sowas
Ich meine, warum hat man ein GitHub-Repo?
Warum, wenn nichts drin ist, man hat Examples drin, ja super, dafür hätte man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
das gebraucht, ja
Also sprich, das, das verstehe ich nicht und, und ich verstehe auch nicht, warum es, also die, sie sagen ja auch, ja, hier, Open Source, ja
Hier, FAQ, will Mojo be open sourced? Over time we expect to, ich, ich verstehe nicht, warum es nicht einfach gleich Open Source ist
Such as the standard is still young, so we continue to incubate, bla bla bla bla bla
Also, ich verstehe, verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, ja, warum, warum? Das schafft ja auch ein gewisses
Vertrauen in die Sprache und in die Technologie und in die Implementierung
Wenn das Open Source ist und man gucken kann, okay, was macht das eigentlich genau? Und das ist halt so ein Ding
Das eine muss ja gar nicht dem anderen widersprechen, man könnte ohne Probleme die Sprache Open Source machen
Ohne, dass man jetzt instant jeden Pull-Request
Reviewt und Approved, ich meine, versuchte mal
Ich meine, guck mal, Sachen wie
Sachen wie .NET oder, oder
Oder Chrome oder sowas, ja, die sind auch Open Source, ja, aber
Contributed mal zu Chrome oder
Contributed mal zu irgendeinem etwas nicht ganz so, zu irgendeinem, zu irgendeinem Open-Source-Projekt, was irgendeiner großen Firma gehört, das ist teilweise, da musste
durch übelst viele, übelst viele Ringe springen, so, bitte, bitte signe hier das Contribution-Form
Und jetzt beantworte uns noch diese 500 Fragen und dann
Reviewen wir das und lehnen es ab und sowas in der Richtung, also
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als könntest du da easy irgendwas Contributen, das heißt, das müssten die auch gar nicht machen, aber es ist ein Unterschied zwischen
Man kann sich den Source-Code angucken versus man guckt sich jeden Pull-Request an, die könnten auch genauso gut sagen, erst mal keine Pull-Requests
Wir entwickeln das erst mal, bis es in einem Stand ist, wo wir denken, dass es jetzt
sich dafür eignet, aber ich finde es halt blöd, dass es nicht direkt Open-Source ist, ja
Wir können ja mal kurz schauen
Was denn?
Ja, gibt es immer mal wieder Fragen dazu
Discord expanded on the answer, ich bin nicht eingeloggt in Discord, wie wäre es, wenn die es einfach in ihre FAQ schreiben anstatt im Discord?
Naja gut
Ja, aber so viel, so viel dazu, mein
Ausprobieren werden wir sicherlich irgendwann mal, aber ihr wisst ja, ich bin nicht der allergrößte Python-Hacker, man
Ja, ich finde es keine schlussige Erklärung, ist Delphi nicht Close-Source, das kann sein
Das kann sein, aber du musst mal gucken, aus welcher Zeit Delphi ist, Delphi kommt von 1987 oder sowas
Okay, 1995
Also ich schaue ein bisschen
Da war das generell mit Open-Source noch nicht so, nicht so weit hin, ja
Muss der Source-Code nicht eh installiert werden, damit man ein Programm kompilieren kann? Nö, nö, nö, warum?
Du brauchst den Source-Code von deinem Programm, was du kompilieren willst
Du brauchst nicht den Source-Code vom Compiler oder von der Standard-Library oder sonst was, oder irgendwelche anderen Entwickler-Tools
Du brauchst den Source-Code von deinem Programm
Ansonsten, ansonsten brauchst du das nicht, ich meine, guck mal, du kannst ja auch den
Microsoft C++-Compiler nehmen, wer sowas machen will, man weiß ja nie
Und damit, ich glaube nicht, dass der Open-Source ist und damit deine Programme übersetzen, du brauchst deinen Source-Code, aber den Compiler oder den
vom Framework oder Standard-Library oder irgendwelche
Plugins für die IDE und sowas brauchst du nicht, ja
Ja, C++ ist halt so ein Ding, es gibt halt kein C++, was Open-Source ist in dem Sinn, es gibt C++-Implementierung, es gibt aber halt leider
das ist so, bei C ist es nicht so wild, C ist so simpel und übersichtlich, da tut sich auch nicht viel
aber
bei C++ ist halt so ein Ding, das ist auch einer der Kritikpunkte, die ich daran habe, warum
ich, also ich kann es euch sagen, warum es das nicht gibt, aber warum gibt es keine offizielle
Standard-Implementierung für C++, das würde auch dafür sorgen, dass es nicht so ein Wildwuchs gibt, dass teilweise Features gibt, die im Standard
2005 oder so eingeführt wurden, aber noch kein Compiler richtig unterstützt oder der meiste Kram nicht richtig oder
Undefined Behavior, ich kann euch sagen, warum es keine Referenz-Implementierung von C++ gibt, weil dann das C++-Gremium
ihren eigenen Scheiß benutzen müsste, den sie sich ausdenken, da haben die keinen Bock drauf
Das, was die sich ausdenken, niemand will das implementieren, keiner Bock drauf, dass irgendwelche
Armsäcke, die an GCC oder
LLVM oder wo auch immer dran, LLVM dran arbeiten, nee, wie heißt das?
LLVM? LVVM? LLVM? Alter, wie heißt das nochmal?
Ich glaube so, oder?
Ja, arbeiten
Nein, es gibt, es gibt einen C++-Standard, es gibt keine C++-Referenz-Implementierung
dieses Standards, es gibt ein paar Textdokumente, wo ganz wildes Zeug drin steht bei C++
Aber es gibt keine offizielle Referenz-Implementierung
Weil dann müssten sie ihren eigenen Müll benutzen und vielleicht feststellen, dass es scheiße ist, was sie sich ausgedacht haben die letzten 15 Jahre über
zumindest in großen Teilen
So, was haben wir denn heute auf YouTube zu gucken?
Jetzt
Sieht jetzt die Zukunft bei dir ein? Kommt drauf an
Cyberpunk 2.0
Technik-Job als Quereinsteiger, krisensicherer Beruf als Aufzugstechniker. Oh ja, Aufzüge braucht man immer
Müssen wir mal gucken. Chat-Gib, ich wollte ja noch gucken, was auf GitHub so trendet. Habe ich auch noch gar nicht gemacht
Ist GCC nicht die Standard-Implementierung? Nee
Und dafür hat GCC auch einiges vom Standard gar nicht drin
Es gibt eine schöne Übersicht-Seite, ich weiß nicht, ob ich die jetzt finde
C++-Implementations
Overview
Standards, ich weiß nicht
Da gab es irgendwo war so eine schöne Seite mit so einer hässlichen
Schlecht gemachten Tabelle
Wo drin steht, welche Compiler was
unterstützen
Ja, vielleicht
Ja
genau
Oh nein, C++, ist es soweit? Es ist soweit. MonkaS, es gibt C++
Okay
Es geht weiter, Leute, es geht weiter
Okay, lasst uns mal kurz reingucken, was gibt es für C++
2026 Features?
Da gibt es doch, gibt doch nichts. Es gibt, es gibt doch nichts. Nee, nee, gibt's, gibt's doch nicht
Ja, also zumindest hier gibt's, hier gibt's eine Übersicht, was die, was die Compiler alle supporten, so
Da sieht man schon mal, dass, okay, das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt ein bisschen unfair, ja
Weil C++
26 ist in Ordnung, wenn die das noch nicht alles, alles supporten, aber gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns mal die 2000, guck mal, wie man hier schon sieht
Die 2023 an, ja
Und es gibt keine Referenz-Implementierung
Guckt, guckt, es gibt auch Sachen, GCC mag vielleicht noch mit die Kompletteste sein, aber auch GCC hat nicht alles
Nee
Nein, es gibt, es gibt, glaube ich, es gibt, glaube ich, nicht einen C++-Compiler, der den Standard komplett implementiert, wo man auch schon mal sieht, dass es irgendwie komplett an der Realität vorbeigeht
Gehen wir mal weiter
Okay, das sind 23 Features, das ist ja okay, das ist jetzt vielleicht noch super aktuell und so, gehen wir mal weiter, 20 Features
Na, da sieht, da sieht GCC, äh, Modules
Ja, das Mod, Modules wird wahrscheinlich so ein Ding sein, da können wir in C++ in 50 Jahren noch mal gucken und die hantieren noch mit Header-Files rum
Ja, da sieht C++ und, und, äh, ja, manche sprechen es Klang aus
Doch relativ gut aus, aber auch nicht alles
Ja, hier sieht's, hier sieht's ganz gut aus
Ja, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal bei 17
Da ist mittlerweile alles dabei, guckt, da haben sie alles
Also, ja, C++ ist das, äh, GCC ist das am nächsten, was wir haben am Standard dran, ja
Aber der Witz ist halt
Der Witz ist halt, wenn man sich das hier anguckt
Diese
Die Sachen hier, es ist halt, hä, wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht, die Sachen sind halt wieder absolut, absolut nicht verständlich, ja
Nehmen wir mal das als Beispiel
Na gut, das kann man
Die Sonntags
Die Sonntags ist so, und das ist jetzt noch hübsches C++, ja, die ist so unglaublich hässlich immer
Ich mein, wer zum Teufel, das liest sich so kacke einfach nur
Und das geht jetzt noch, das geht jetzt noch
Das geht noch viel schlimmer
Naja, okay, lass mal kurz gucken, was trendet denn die Woche
Game Engine, ja, da hat der Unity-CEO mit zu beigetragen
OpenTofu, manage your cloud infrastructure, okay, was ist das? Das kenne ich nicht
Gibt's da
Gibt's da irgendein
Irgendein Beispiel
OpenTofu
Infrastructure as Code Tool, Docs, Introduction
Äh
Get in it
Terraform, hä, und warum brauche ich da jetzt noch Tofu obendrauf, hä, hä
Okay, es wäre mega nice, würden die einfach mal erklären
Multicloud Deployments
Das heißt, es gibt, das hat, das, das, jetzt ist das eine Sammlung von Terraform-Modulen oder sowas
Ach, das ist Terraform, das ist der Terraform-Fork
System-Art ging komplett an mir vor, ich wusste, dass sie das, dass die Terraform-Fork, ich wusste nicht, dass man das OpenTofu
Ach, das ist der Terraform-Fork
Jetzt ergibt, okay, dann verstehe ich auch, warum das so viele
Ja, nice, das müssen wir auch gleich mal starren
Ja, hier, ja
Okay
Das ist, jetzt verstehe ich das, das ist der Terraform-Fork, interessant, ja
Sehr schön, das finde ich gut
Ich, ich, ich bin gespannt, ob sich das durchsetzt, aber
Dann haben wir vielleicht eine gute Alternative
Mal schauen
Text-to-Speech, okay, Plain, Jira
Jira
Open Source Jira
Was soll das sein?
Ein Open Source Jira
Das ist, das ist
Im Prinzip ein Ticketsystem, oder?
Weil das sieht gar nicht aus wie Jira
Das ist
Hat bloß jemand hingeschrieben, weil es cool klingt, oder?
Jira
Das sieht ehrlich gesagt komplett anders aus
Und es ist ein
Pricing
Okay, also immer
Jira
Das ist kein Web
Das ist kein
Browser-Tool, das ist
Irgendwie so
Elektronen-mäßig, oder?
Hätte ich jetzt vermutet
Ich meine, man kann das sicherlich selbst hosten
Und dann ist es free, solange man will
Ja, start with Docker Compose
Also das ist auf jeden Fall zum Selbsthosten
Naja, gut
Jira
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
AI
Eine weitere Note-Taking-Application
Da gibt es ja auch 30 Milliarden von für
Aber sicherlich
Ohne
Mobile-Apps
Und deswegen schon meistens nicht brauchbar
Baby
Hysteria
Das ist China-Chinesen-Proxy
Very good
Very good whiteboard
AI
Äh, AI
Power
PowerShell
C++-Shit
Kamal
Was ist das?
Deploy Web-Apps everywhere
Dynamic Reverse-Proxy
Traffic Hold Recalls
Was?
Ist das eine
So eine Art
TCP-Session
Sharing
Ding für mehrere Backends
Oder sowas
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll
Ich gucke, was auf GitHub trendet
Check ich nicht
Was es ist, ehrlich gesagt
So genau
Also die
Keine Ahnung
Tabby
Moment, ist das nicht
Das ist nicht das Terminal, wo du den Login brauchst, oder?
Äh
Das ist irgendwelches
AI-Zeug
AI
Game-Engine
Node
Most advanced frontend
Track-and-Drop-Builder
Also quasi was für Frontpage
Hackerman-Zeug
Universal-Proxy-Plattform
Das ist doch bestimmt auch irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding, oder?
Okay
Was ist das jetzt?
Kann man das aufmachen ohne, dass man auf irgendeine
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
FAQ
Was bin ich sehen?
Ist das
Das ist doch bestimmt irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding
Ja, ja, ist es
China-Chinesen-Ding, um die China-Firewall zu umgehen
Okay
Alles klar
Jo, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Hi Max
Wie findest du Custom-Tastaturen?
Weiß ich nicht, ich hab nie eine gehabt
Hast du schon mal was mit F-Sharp gemacht?
Nee, nee, hab ich nicht
Weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin
Es werden auch immer noch Leute gesucht für Kobol
Okay
Nee, hab ich keinen Bock drauf
F-Sharp gibt's, keine Ahnung, drei Entwickler auf der Welt
Oder so
Auch nicht, warum das Microsoft
Ich mein ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich würde Microsoft besser tun
So eins, zwei richtig beliebte Features
Von F-Sharp nochmal nach C-Sharp zu bringen
Und dann F-Sharp einfach F-Sharp sein zu lassen
Ey, dann
Dann würd ich auch sagen Keck Leaf
So, was können wir uns denn angucken?
Der Aufzug
Ich will jetzt wissen, was der Aufzugstechniker verdient
Was verdient
Was verdient der Aufzugstechniker?
Ist die nicht eigentlich schon recht alt?
Was meinst du, F-Sharp?
Nö
Also
Im Vergleich zu
F-Sharp gibt's
Seit was weiß ich
2014 oder sowas
Möglich
F-Sharp gibt's
Auch nicht so lange
Was? Achso
Ja, das war erst ein Research-Projekt
Was keiner benutzt hat
Ja, genau
Seit 2010
Ne, ne
2010, ja, das kommt eher hin
Also wirklich benutzt hat das kaum einer
Bis 2014, 2015
Das ist so die Zeit, wo dann auch so langsam
Ein bisschen so der
Sagen wir mal, nicht der Hype
Aber so diese
Die Leute realisiert haben
Funktionale Elemente von Programmiersprachen
Durchaus was ganz Praktisches sind
So
Ein Beispiel hat fast jede Sprache heute
Sowas ähnliches wie Pattern-Matching
Oder
Anonyme
So Inline-Funktionen und sowas
Hat eigentlich mittlerweile jede größere Programmiersprache
Mal gut, mal schlecht
C++ hat von allem plusse schlechte bekommen
Und
Das Gute in abartiger Syntax
Guckt euch die Lambda-Syntax in C++ an
Oder die Async
Hat jemand mal die Async-Await-Syntax in C++ gesehen?
MonkaW
Kennt ihr die?
Moment
Okay
Das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen unfair
Das sind jetzt nur
Kann man hier anklicken, das sind nur die groben Syntax-Definitionen
Aber guckt euch das mal an, Alter
Wie das aussieht
Ich mein, seriously
Das ist jetzt unfair
Das sind nur die quasi
Der theoretische Aufbau
Aber wie das aussieht schon
Wisst ihr
Alle anderen Sprachen schaffen es irgendwie so
Okay, das ist
Das ist Feature XY
Und so ist ein minimal Beispiel
Wie du es verwendest
Aber nein, nicht C++
Wenn ich sowas hier schon sehe
Autostandard Forward
Policy und Standard Launch
Was?
Ja, beste
Guckt euch die Syntax an
Was ist das?
Das ist so eklig
Standard Async
Standard Launch Async
Das ist die Lambda-Syntax von C++
Alter
Ist das scheiße
Und wo
Hier
Guck mal hier
Auto A3
Hier Standard
Aber
Wait
Auto A3
Standard Async
Standard Launch X
Okay, was ist X
Also ich würde sagen, X ist nicht definiert
Aus meiner Sicht, oder?
Moment
X ist
Ah, X ist Instruct
Obviously
Natürlich ist X Instruct
Das ist quasi ein default initialisiertes
Struct
Wo jetzt
Wo die Call
Wo der Call Operator
Oder wie auch immer man das Ding nennt
Der Aufruf Call Operator
Überladen ist, sodass man ein Struct
Direkt als Funktion aufruft
Meine Fresse, C++ allein schon
Das Beispiel ist ein gutes Beispiel
Für wie beschissen die Sprache ist
Also
Nur mal so
Nur, dass wir das jetzt mal richtig checken
Also
X ist ein Struct
Dadurch, dass man sagt, man möchte
Eine Variable anlegen
Vom Typ X mit dem Namen X
Auch schon ein geiles Beispiel
Ohne, dass man irgendwas dahinter schreibt zum Initialisieren
Wird es default initialisiert
Also alles mit 0 höchstwahrscheinlich
Was nicht schlimm ist, weil es gibt nichts zu initialisieren
So, dieses Struct hat ein paar
Methoden drauf, unter anderem
Ein Operator Overload
Nämlich für Function Calls
Sodass man auf dem Struct
Selbst Function Calls machen kann
Die dann hierhin
Weitergeleitet werden
Das heißt, im Endeffekt
Ruft
X, Klammer auf, Klammer zu
Quasi
Das hier auf
Das ist so unglaublich
Abartig, man
So, und da kommt dann raus, i plus 10
So, und das wird dann
Standard Async, Standard Launch
X und als Parameter
Moment, auf was bezieht sich
Die 43
Achso, auf den, auf den, hier
Auf das Int an der Stelle
Da kommt dann, da kommt dann raus
43 plus 10
Oh man, und das ist
Noch nicht alles, es gibt ja noch
Das ist, das ist ja nur die
Das ist ja nur die halbe Miete
Genau, es gibt dann noch
Core Await
Es ist so abartig, keine Ahnung, niemand
Deswegen, das ist übrigens der Grund
Warum es keine Standard Implementierung von C++ gibt
Weil die Leute, die diesen Standard
Machen, keinen Bock haben, den eigenen
Kack zu implementieren
Danke für die Subs, Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab
Ich guck grad mal nach
Irgendwie muss ich mir was zu trinken holen, gleich mal
Du, du, du, du
Splixer
Wilde Igel, Stripes
Pog-Subscription-Zeule, Leute
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass C++
Von allen gehasst wird, außer irgendwelchen
Merkwürdigen Leuten
Hm
Niemand mag C++
Selbst die Leute, die C++ täglich machen müssen
Mögen C++ nicht
Hi Max, ich mach gerade Ausbildung in Systemintegration
Kannst du mir was empfehlen, wo ich später
Arbeiten könnte? Ja, in so ziemlich allem
Kommt drauf an, was dich interessiert
Du hast früher mal was
Von Cloud gesagt, hab überlegt
In die Serverwartung
Na, Serverwartung
Gibt es nicht
Müsste nicht was Serverwartung sein soll
Was verstehst du unter Serverwartung
Dass man ab und zu mal eine Festplatte tauscht
Dafür braucht man kein Physi
Das kann jeder Hausmeister
Im Rechenzentrum
Da brauchst du, da musst du nix machen
Und das macht auch
Jeder Hausmeister am Rechenzentrum
Weil du heutzutage als Physi
Beziehungsweise als
ITler kaum noch ins Rechenzentrum musst
Wenn du nicht gerade bei dem jeweiligen Cloud-Provider
Oder Provider arbeitest
Oder beim Infrastruktur-Team
Ein Kumpel, vorsicht
Der kümmert sich per Fernwartung um Server
In einer Firma
Ach, sowas meinst du das
Ja, gut
Jaja
Administriert Server für irgendwelche Unternehmen
Ja gut, mein
Wenn die selbst keinen haben
Sind das wahrscheinlich irgendwelche super kleinen Klitschen
Die dann wollen
So nach dem Motto
Ey, wir brauchen
Ich
Eine Seite
Wo draufsteht
Dass wir Urlaub haben oder so
Ich weiß nicht was der da genau macht
Aber das ist nix womit
Irgendwie
Wenn du keine Skills
Und keine Karriere hast
Würde ich mal sagen
Wenn du ab und zu mal per Fernwartung
Für irgendwelche kleinen Klitschen
Server rebootest und updatest
Keine Ahnung
Ich kann das schlecht einstellen
Ich weiß ja nicht was der macht
Keine Ahnung
Das kann ja alles und nichts sein
Aber Serverwartung sagt halt gar nix aus
Sind das Linux-Server
Sind das Windows-Server
Ist ja auch so ein Ding
Laufen die bei der Firma irgendwie im Rack im Keller
Laufen die bei irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter
Muss da irgendwelche
Containerisierungssachen
Orchestriert werden
Das kann ja alles sein
Also das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen
Serverwartung ist wirklich sehr nichtssagend
So
Ich wollte jetzt mal gucken
Was ist eigentlich die Sprache
Die du auf der Arbeit nutzt
Tatsächlich
BASH
Genauso wie hier im Stream
20. September
Da habe ich ein bisschen was raus geschwitzt, das muss ja wieder rein. Gut, übrigens jetzt, wo ihr es gerade, wo ihr es gerade dabei habt
Lasst mich mal kurz gucken, was meine Stonks machen. Was machen meine Stonks? Meine Stonks sagen
Oh, ist wieder ein bisschen weniger geworden. Könnte man noch mal was kaufen, hä?
Not so Stonks sagen die ja, das ist korrekt
Wenn das noch ein bisschen fällt, kaufe ich noch mehr Stonks. Wie viel, wie viel habe ich denn hier noch drauf? Wie viel kann ich denn noch kaufen?
Noch 614 Euro, na das lohnt sich jetzt nicht wirklich
So
Weiter. Ja, es lohnt sich insofern nicht, das hier irgendwie noch reinzustecken, weil das
also
Ich überweise halt regelmäßig was
Und manchmal bleibt halt ein bisschen was übrig, weil es halt nicht glatt aufgeht mit dem, was man, was man kaufen kann
Hast du Bitcoin? Nee
So, aber wir wollen uns jetzt eigentlich den Aufzugstechniker angucken. In dem Bereich, wo wir heute arbeiten, der Berliner Kuhdamm, das ist
Berliner Kuhdamm, ist das irgendein Assi-Viertel oder geht das noch halbwegs?
Kenne mich in Berlin nicht aus. Also in Berlin war ich bisher nur am Hauptbahnhof, am Brandenburger Tor, am
Reichstag heißt es glaube ich, gell
und
ja, in diesen Parks dazwischen
Und viel habe ich nicht gesehen von Berlin
Das ist also eine Sache, die mir in Berlin extrem aufgefallen ist
Und das liegt wahrscheinlich halt durch diese Ost und West-Geschichte
Dass es Straßen gibt
Da ist links alles neu und glänzt und rechts ist alles alt und verfallen
Das habe ich so, so krass noch nirgendswo gesehen
Teilweise echt
katastrophal
Boah, Alter, mach dich so laut. Sag mal, wer mischt diese Sendung ab?
Exzellent Musik hier
Mon Castille
Mon Castille, Mon Castille
Einfach stehen bleiben
So, Handwerker-Pack ausweis ausfüllen. Im Gebäude kannst du halt nicht rauchen, ne?
Muss man alles irgendwie
Warum ist dein Arm so schwarz? Ist das ein Handschuh oder ist das eine Tätowierung?
Das ist irgendwie eine bescheuerte Angewohnheit. Tätowierung. Das ist wie so ein Ritual. Der ist ja komplett schwarz, der Arm
Mit Betreten vom Gebäude
Geht es dann weiter mit Arbeitsschutz?
Morgen!
Ich stehe auf dem Kuhdamm vorne
Wenn er an den Etagen vorbeifährt, in der Abwärtsfahrt, kommt DX und fällt ab
Ja, UX bleibt angezogen
UX bleibt angezogen. Würde ich auch so sehen
Also, wenn ich oben einsteige und mir jede Etage von oben nach unten wünsche, fährt er alle brav ab
Das macht er in der Aufwärtsfahrt nicht
Dann machen wir jetzt nämlich folgendes, weil wir einen
Schütz tauschen wollen
Ein Schütz?
Jetzt bin ich auf der sicheren Seite. Jetzt gibt es
Guck mal, es wird erst mal gemessen. So ein Teil habe ich auch
Das wäre ich jetzt hier eins zu eins. Wie heißt das Ding? Ein Duspol oder so, gell?
Was heißt das so? Wo sind die Electric-Course-Experts hier?
Guck mal, die guten Wera-Kraftform-VDE-Schraubendreher
Ach nee, Duspol ist der Hersteller
FR haben wir ausgebaut. Bezeichnen wir das Bauteil noch
Eine kleine Probefahrt
Ist wie mit der Flex oder wie mit dem Dremel. Der Dremel ist ja auch nur der Hersteller. Ihr hört schon, das schaltet jetzt auch akustisch viel sauberer
Er hält an in der Etage, macht was er soll
Alle unsere Sachen weg, Licht aus
Genau, also mit dem Auto, das ist so, dass ich den
Zur Privatnutzung auch überlassen bekommen habe im Rahmen der
Ein-Prozent-Regelung
Ich finde das super cool, also du hast ja wirklich alles mit drin. Wenn man so viele Autos fährt, warum nicht?
Du zahlst keine Versicherungen, keine Steuern
Wartung, Instandhaltung, TÜV etc. pp. Ist alles mit drin
Ich finde es immer interessant, dass man über die Jahre immer anhand der Geräusche erkennt, was der Aufzug gerade macht
Ja, kann ich verstehen. Ist bei vielen Technikgeräten so. Und ihr werdet es kennen, vielleicht von euch, sowas simples wie euer Computer, wenn der jeden Tag neben euch steht und an ist
Ihr erkennt an den Geräuschen teilweise schon, wie schnell die Lüfter drehen, Festplattenaktivität und sowas
Ungefähr, ob was nicht stimmt
Ja, so wenn auf einmal beispielsweise die Festplatte rattert, denkt ihr auch, hä, was ist jetzt los?
Dann seht ihr, ah, ok, der Windows-Search-Indexer macht wieder irgendeinen Scheiß
Das erkennt man mit der Zeit und so ist das bei Aufzügen wahrscheinlich
Ist da noch ein bisschen mehr Mechanik drin, auch so
Wer hat noch Festplatten?
Ich habe noch eine Festplatte drin, weil irgendwo braucht man ja auch was mit ordentlich Speicherplatz
Also ich habe, ja, ich habe SSD, SSD, Kack-SSD und noch eine altere SSD und noch eine Festplatte
Das mit, übrigens, das was hier steht, stimmt nicht so ganz, die ist einfach nicht gemountet
Die, also, die ist Veracrypt-Encrypted und das sieht man hier nicht
Oh, jetzt wird geklettert
Abseilungs-Champ
Das ist das erste und letzte Mal
Und bei dem Aufzug hier ist es nun mal so, dass es diese Absturzgefahr gibt und dann muss man halt darauf Rücksicht nehmen
Wada-bums-Dings, danke schön für den Zap
Bist du, bist du Max-FPS? Ich bin Wobblers
Wir bräuchten hier ein Geländer, was mindestens 700 hoch ist
Dann wäre im Prinzip
Aber die Frage, aber die Frage kommt öfters
Gefahr beseitigt
Okay, jetzt bin ich, bin ich sicher
Habe ich dich einfach nur genug G-Baited oder G-Baitest du mich jetzt?
Also muss das Geländer einfach mal ein paar Zentimeter höher, so 25 Zentimeter mehr
Früher hat das ausgereicht, heute nicht mehr
Und dazu mache ich jetzt ein paar Bilder hier von der Konstruktion
Und dann wird ein Angebot erstellt, damit das Geländer vergrößert wird
Da wird der Aufzugbetreiber sagen, fix mein Aufzug und nerv mich nicht mit dem Geländer
Ich bin davon überzeugt, dass ich einen absolut krisensicheren Job habe
Berlin ist geografisch begrenzt
Es werden immer mehr Leute in der Stadt, es wird immer mehr gebaut
In die Breite können sie nicht mehr, also müssen sie hoch
Die Leute haben keine Lust drücken zu steigen, also was brauchen sie?
Einen Aufzug
Ich kenne keinen arbeitslosen Aufzugsmonter
Schlüssige Argumentation, klingt nachvollziehbar, ja
Pimpo Food
Ja, da gibt es sich immer sehr viel Mühe
Wenn man dann sagt, ich hätte gerne eine kleine Stulle
Dann wird das hier immer so ein Semi-Sandwich
Aber auch wieder mit Gurke und Krimskrabens aus dem eigenen Garten
Mir wird das wahrscheinlich gar nicht reichen
Das Modell von Aufzug ist ziemlich
Alt?
Tricky
Na gut, dann fahren wir da einfach mal hin
Locker, flockig
Leute, ratet mal, was es bei mir zu essen gibt
Der einzige Hinweis, den ich habe ist
Aufzug außer Betrieb
Du lernst jeden Tag dazu
Jede Störung ist ja nicht wie die andere
Jeden Tag, wenn du nach Hause kommst
Nudeln mit Lachs
Ich wusste, dass das jetzt kommt, Nudeln mit Lachs
Nein, ich habe euch typiert
Es gibt heute kein Nudeln mit Lachs
Ich wollte es nur hören, ob ihr es noch wisst
Nein, es gibt heute keine Nudeln mit Lachs
Ich weiß gar nicht, was es heute gibt
Ich glaube, ich habe noch
Es gibt auch nicht Nudeln mit Tomatensauce
Was gibt es denn?
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Nein, nein, nein
Ich glaube
Was gibt es denn?
Ich glaube, Reis gibt es noch
Reis
Ich glaube, Reis
Ich weiß es gar nicht jetzt
Wieder ein Stück Wissen mehr in deinen Wissenskoffer gepackt
Tricky Fahrstuhlmodell
Schau jetzt in die Steuerung rein
Was hier so los ist
Ich klicke
Das sieht nach einer Türstörung der Kabintür aus
Ich möchte erst mal den Dreck hier raus machen
Was mich auch stört, ist, dass manche Menschen
kein Verständnis dafür haben, dass ich meine Arbeit machen muss
Da werden dann Flaschen nach dir geworfen
What?
Nach dir wird gespuckt
Warum?
Du wirst beschimpft
Warum zum Teufel?
Na gut, wir sind in Berlin, dürfen wir nicht vergessen
In Berlin ist das alles nicht so normal
Aber warum sollte man nach einem Aufzugsmonteur
eine Flasche werfen?
Ich meine, will man nicht, dass der Aufzug wieder funktioniert?
Aber es ist Berlin, das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
Ich meine, in Frankfurt kann dir das auch passieren
Aber in Berlin ist nochmal, was das angeht
wahrscheinlich nochmal eine härtere Nummer
Früher
bei der Bahn
da ist einem schon sowas öfter untergekommen
Wir haben jetzt zwar einen Fremdkörper entfernt
aus der Türschwelle
Aber hier sind verschiedene Sicherheitskontakte
Der ist verbogen, ne?
Der scheint auch schon mal ein bisschen nass geworden zu sein
ein bisschen rostig
Und den machen wir neu
So, let's go
Alter Marv, was ist da los?
Ich wurde bei einer Personenbefreiung
Also
Da war jemand im Fahrstuhl eingeschlossen, oder?
Ich wurde bei einer Personenbefreiung
schon mal mit einem Messer bedroht
in Düsseldorf
Musste dann die Polizei
Ja, aber was ist das denn?
Was ist das denn?
Musste dann die Polizei
Ja, aber warum?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft
Also
Wollten die nicht, dass du die Person rausholst?
Oder was?
Also, was muss in einem
Warum bedroht man denjenigen
der den anderen aus dem Fahrstuhl befreien will?
Also
Was
Weiß man, was das
Ich nenne mal das Motiv von dem war
Also, was der sich gedacht hat dabei
Ich verstehe die
Ich meine
Es ist jetzt
Wenn du da jetzt anrücken würdest
Und sagen
Okay
Um den Fahrstuhl wieder funktionieren zu machen
Muss
Muss ich das Kabel abschneiden
Und du crashst jetzt halt 50 Meter runter
Kann ich auch nichts machen, ja?
Dann würde ich mich auch versuchen zu wehren
Aber wenn du versuchst einfach nur die Leute rauszuholen
Hä?
Okay
Keine Ahnung, was mit denen los ist
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn einer vorbeikommt
und mich aus dem Fahrstuhl rausholt
Eigentlich sind Leute einfach nur PP-Ger
Low IQ
Und
Wer weiß, was die sich noch alles reingeschmissen haben
Ja, aber gerade deswegen müsste man sich doch eigentlich freuen
Wenn derjenige kommt, der einen rausholt, oder?
Ja, ich sag ja nur
Dann könnte ich es ja verstehen, wenn sich einer aufregt
So
Oh, ich will jetzt nicht crashen mit dem Fahrstuhl
Einfach so
Hey, ich hole dich jetzt aus dem Fahrstuhl raus
In dem du eingesperrt bist
Nein, komm nicht näher
Hä?
Ja, das stimmt schon, gut
Wer
Wer weiß
Das ist eigentlich ein bisschen wie in Frankfurt
Wenn du da durch irgendwelche
Straßen gehst
Dort
Wo halt die ganzen
Super-Assis rumhängen
Da kloppen sich auch öfters mal random Leute
Auf der Straße
Oder flitzen
Von 0 auf 100
Schräg über die Straße
Und schreien rum und sowas
Es ist nicht direkt Hauptbahnhof
Es ist eher so Nidda-Straße
Und so ein bisschen drumherum
Aber trotzdem
Weißt du auch nicht, was da die nächste
Nächste Minute passiert
Schauen
Unterschied
Das hier ist der alte
Der ist
Verbogen
Das ist der neue
Der ist wieder in Originalposition
Ja
Beste
In Originalposition
Ja
Werra
Werra-Kraftform
VDE
Set
Fest ist halt der Kumpel
Prima
Probefahrt nochmal
Also
Mein Gehalt
Ist in Anlehnung
An den IG Metall Tarifvertrag
Und mit der
Lohngruppe
In der ich eingruppiert bin
Habe ich immer
So ein bedingungsloses
Grundgehalt
Von etwa
3.900 Euro
Brutto
Dann komme ich
In einem sehr schlechten
Monat
Mit wenig Zuschlägen
Auf
Bei Steuerklasse 1
Etwa auf
2.600
2.700 Euro netto
Es gibt
Bei uns natürlich
Ich meine
Das ist jetzt nicht krass viel
Auch gerade für 5-3 Stunden
Aber ich denke mal
Das ist durchaus
Durchaus
Okay
Viele viele Zuschläge
Für Arbeiten
Im versetzten Dienst
Am Wochenende
In der Nacht
Am Feiertag
Was man halt
So kennt
Kommt jetzt doch
Urlaubsgeld
Weihnachtsgeld
Prämien
Die wir bekommen
Dazu
Dann sind die Nettobeträge
Natürlich noch höher
Und das ist dann so
Ja das ist doch nicht schlecht
Durch die ganzen Zuschläge
Dann doch schon
Auf ein relativ
Hohes
Jahresgehalt
Von
58.000 Euro
Dann kommt
Als Handwerker
Und das ist
Finde ich schon
Eine Hausnummer
Muss ich sagen
Guten Tag
Oh
Stürmische Begrüßung
So
Ja
Hi
Na hallo
Na
Wo ist unser Ritual
Da ist es
Ha ha ha
Das war Bäuchlein kraulen
Ja
Wenn er nicht nach Hause kommt
Wupp Pet
So recht wieder
Ha ha ha
Jetzt gehen wir also
Noch ne Gassi
Hier zu viert
Und zwar
Meine Tochter
Mein Stiefsohn
Meine Partnerin
Und meine Wenigkeit
Wir haben das
Das Haus hier
Zu sehr sehr
Moderaten
Finanziellen
Aufwendungen erhalten
Weil
Das
Über ihre Eltern
Quasi gekommen ist
Das macht mich
Echt entspannt
Dass ich weiß
Also
125k für ein Haus
Ist glaube ich
Echt wenig
Das ist meins
Theoretisch
Kann es mir keiner
Wegnehmen
Und
Später im Alter
Bin ich halt
Einfach abgesichert
Was mein Wohnort
Angeht
Also ich bin
Der klassische
Sparer
Ich investiere
Nicht in irgendwelche
Kryptowährungen
Oder in andere
Immobilien
Oder Aktien
Oder sowas
Günstiger
Das ist der
Einzigste Luxus
Den ich mir
Persönlich gönne
Habe ich jetzt
Seit 2 Jahren
Hab ich gebraucht
Gekauft
Hab sie relativ
Ich sag immer gerne
Preiswert
Bekommen
Oh shit
Ich weiß was es ist
Das ist
Ein Main
Aber
Das kann ich jetzt
Nicht spielen
Weil Toss
Toss
Sowas
Das läuft immer noch
Im Hintergrund
Tauchprobe
Könnt ihr haben
Genau
Dann ziehen wir
uns jetzt
Einmal um
Beziehungsweise
ich ziehe mich
Einmal kurz um
Und dann
Haben
Wir jetzt drüben
Bei der Feuerwehr
Was zu tun
Also wir
Haben
Jeden
Dienstag
Übungsdienst
Ich kenne auch einen, der bei der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr ist.
Ich weiß nicht, Freiwillige Feuerwehr, das sind immer so ganz spezielle, spezielle Leute, die das freiwillig, also die das machen.
Wir hatten auch einen, also ich kenne nur einen, der bei der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr ist.
Und der hatte laufend irgendwelche Lehrgänge.
Keine Ahnung, Kranlehrgang, Kettensägenlehrgang, 1-5, Axtlehrgang, alle möglichen Dinger.
Und der ist da auch voll drin aufgegangen.
Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber es ist bestimmt Tors, weil alle Musik Tors ist.
...auf Funktionalität.
Ja, also bedeutet, wir bauen die Leiter einmal vollständig auf.
Soll ich euch wieder runterholen?
Ja.
Okay.
Jetzt geht es schon ein bisschen berlinerisch los.
Soll ich euch runterholen?
Ich habe mir diesen Wunsch halt erfüllt.
Diesen Kindheitswunsch.
Ich wollte Feuerwehrmann sein und das Handwerk wollte ich auch immer machen.
Und das ist halt diese Vereinbarung zwischen das und dem Hobby mit der Feuerwehr.
Da hast du aber echt den ganzen Tag was zu tun, oder?
Ich habe alles Beides zusammen.
Weil ich bin jemand in unserer Gesellschaft, der gesagt hat, egal was am Ende dabei rauskommt,
ich habe meine Zeit dafür investiert und habe wenigstens den Versuch unternommen, den Menschen zu helfen.
Okay.
Ehrenwerte, Ehrenwerte, Absichten.
Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors.
Ich habe es aufgegeben, irgendwelchen Menschen helfen zu wollen.
Das Einzige, denen ich helfe, sind irgendwelche Tiere im Tierheim.
Menschen sind mir egal.
Also außer Angehörige und Nahestehende, ja.
Und unter Chat.
So, jetzt wollte ich gerade mal gucken, was kam jetzt eigentlich raus.
Monatlich 3K umgeführt.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht.
Für einen handwerklichen Beruf ist das bestimmt ziemlich gut.
Bleibt noch massig Geld über.
Ja, nice.
Aber was man halt bei dem gesehen hat ist,
im Vergleich zu der Excel-Schubser-Vermögens-
Ne, nicht Vermögens-
Unternehmensberaterin
macht er halt auch den ganzen Tag was.
Und irgendwie was Sinnvolles.
Der Auer.
Willst du nicht mal dem Chat was spenden?
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Das ist falsch rum.
Der Chat kann Prime-Subscribe.
Oder einfach sein lassen.
Ich bin nicht für die Subs hier.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier Schönes?
Ja, also das war wirklich
der Bullshit-Job schlechthin.
Die Excel-Tabellen-Erstellerin,
die sie da mal in einem Beitrag hatten.
Murk, sehr danke für den Sub.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Die Zukunft ist jetzt endlich an.
Diese Kühler, ey.
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt,
ob sich da irgendwas getan hat.
Was hab ich eigentlich?
Ich hab einen iPhone 14, glaube ich.
Oder was ist denn das? Lass mich mal kurz draufgucken.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Steht das hinten drauf, was man hat?
Wenn ich-
Moment, das sieht man doch.
Chat-Gear, sieht man das in den Settings?
Settings.
In den Settings.
General wahrscheinlich.
About.
iPhone 14 Pro ist das, genau.
Aber nicht das Max.
Das Max war mir zu groß.
Mal gucken, was sich da-
Gucken,
was sich da getan hat.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich würde keinem
empfehlen, sich das iPhone 14 oder 15 Pro
zu- 15 war ich nicht, aber das iPhone 14 Pro
generell pro-
Ganz ehrlich, eigentlich Preis-Leistungs-mäßig
ist das ziemlich kacke.
Das ist viel zu teuer
und
die Features, die es da gibt,
es ist jetzt nicht so, als würde ich das unbedingt
brauchen. Also ich hab mir das gekauft,
weil ich mir gedacht hab, oh nice,
120 Hertz
auf dem- also 120
Hertz Display auf dem
Smartphone und hier und geil
und ganz ehrlich, überhaupt kein
großes Ding. Also
wenn man das ausschaltet,
man merkt kaum den Unterschied dazwischen.
Also man merkt den schon.
Man merkt den, ja. Also gerade
als jemand, der so ein bisschen PC Gaming
Erfahrung hat und ich merke
den Unterschied sofort, gerade bei
Animationen vom Flüssigkeitsgrad
her, aber
man- also es ist-
also man merkt ihn kaum, dass es
irgendwie störend ist.
Also dass du sagst, oh nee,
das ist die Animation. Es ist nicht so, dass die Animationen
nervig sind. Also du merkst es in der
täglichen Bedienung kaum, da guckst du dir jetzt
ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwelche
Animationen an, wie flüssig sich Fenster
in die Taskübersicht begeben und
nicht, sondern im normalen Bedienen wischst du
schnell drüber, da guckst du dir kaum die Animationen an,
da fällt es kaum auf.
Ja, ganz. Moment, das
es gibt den Microsoft Defender im
App Store? Alter, was ist das?
Gut, ich meine, es gibt auch den Microsoft
Defender für Linux. Gibt's ja auch Leute,
die den verwenden. Schaust du Filme,
Serien eigentlich in Englisch?
Ja, die meisten.
Die meisten.
Nicht alles.
Aber die meisten Sachen.
Das ist das iPhone 15 Pro
und augenscheinlich ist es ein kleines
Upgrade, aber Apple hat viele Dinge
verbessert, die ich mir seit Jahren gewünscht habe.
Naja, dass das Ding USB-C
hat, das liegt jetzt ja weniger an Apple.
Und Apple,
muss ich ja mal sagen, ganz im Ernst,
auch wenn die jetzt
ganz toll USB-C,
das hätten die seit Jahren schon machen können
mit USB-C. Und trotzdem
haben sie jetzt nochmal eins obendrauf gesetzt,
wenn du einfach nur
irgendein 0815 USB-C Kabel
anschließt, dann kannst du nur mit USB 2.0
beziehungsweise, nee, es ist ja nicht
USB 2.0, sondern bestimmt
USB 4.2
1 mal 0.5
X3 oder so.
Also mit USB 2.0 Geschwindigkeit
übertragen. Das ist halt echt
dämlich. Max, welche
IT-Richtungen sind am besten bezahlt?
Kann man so pauschal nicht
sagen. Das, was gesucht
wird. Du kannst mit
allem Geld verdienen.
Ich würde pauschal,
ohne Mist, Leute.
Ich würde pauschal nicht mal sagen,
dass Management unbedingt
am besten bezahlt
ist. Wenn es,
sagen wir mal so, Management ist tendenziell schon immer
ganz gut bezahlt, aber da gibt es auch nicht so viele
Positionen. Und
es gibt
auch wenige Positionen, die man wirklich
für mich kann ich jetzt nur sprechen,
die man machen möchte. Da muss man
schon der passende Typ für sein.
Mainframe-Programmierer, ja?
Also ganz ehrlich, du kannst mit
allem richtig gut Kohle verdienen.
Du musst dich halt gut auskennen.
Du kannst auch, wie gesagt, du kannst als
Kobold-Programmierer gut Geld verdienen.
Du kannst wahrscheinlich sogar als
Experte für Windows-Krempel
gut Geld verdienen. Also insofern
such dir
was raus, was dir gefällt
und guck,
dass du da drin richtig Ahnung hast. Weil umso mehr Ahnung
du da drin hast, umso höher sind die Chancen,
dass du in dem Bereich arbeiten kannst
und umso höher sind dadurch die Chancen, dass du
in dem Bereich arbeitest, der dir Bock macht.
Was ist es denn? Was ist es denn?
Was ist das denn hier?
Quote 9
PA?
Was ist es denn, was dir so Bock macht
zum größten Teil?
Ach ja, und was man auch sagen muss, was ich
finde, ist auch wichtig. Man muss sich doch
recht breit auskennen. Das schadet nicht.
Ja, man kann seine Spezialgebiete haben,
das ist sinnvoll, das ist
auch insofern wichtig, weil das
die Sachen ist, wofür man am Ende dann auch
die fette Kohle kriegt, aber
breites Know-How in
allen Gebieten hilft einem unglaublich
diesen einen, in diesem
einen Gebiet
das noch besser hinzukriegen, weil
es reicht oftmals nicht, sich
nur in einem Gebiet auszukennen.
Man muss auch erstmal so ein bisschen drumherum
verstehen, was da
eigentlich passiert, ja.
Deswegen kann ich auch nur jedem empfehlen,
der Physik gelernt hat und
jetzt so klassische Admin-Sachen macht,
sich ein bisschen so mit
Softwareentwicklung zu beschäftigen.
Und ich kann auch jedem Softwareentwickler sich
nur empfehlen, sich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen,
okay, wie baut man beispielsweise
einen Container für seine Anwendung,
wie lässt man das beispielsweise auf irgendeiner
Linux-VM laufen,
wie wird sowas eingerichtet und so.
Das hilft unterm Strich
auf beiden Seiten, wenn man sich ein bisschen
mit dem Bereich der anderen Seite auskennt.
Zumal das eh immer weiter
zusammenwächst, ich meine diese ganze
DevOps-Geschichte ist ja das beste
Beispiel für, dass es immer weiter
zusammenwächst.
Wenn man das Ganze jetzt im
DevOps-Subreddit fragen würde,
da kommen dann Leute um die Ecke und sagen
actually DevOps
ist gar keine Jobbezeichnung.
Ja gut, das ist aber egal, was die Leute
auf Reddit sagen,
weil wenn ihr in ein Stellenportal
geht und sucht nach DevOps,
findet ihr ganz viele Stellen dafür, also
vollkommen unerheblich, was Reddit
meint, dazu sagen
zu müssen. Aber allein schon,
dass es diesen Bereich gibt,
spricht ja dafür, dass da
die Überschneidungen immer größer werden.
Genau, und außerdem verstehen viele
Unternehmen ein bisschen was anderes drunter.
Studiengebiete? Keine Ahnung.
Von
Studium habe ich keine Ahnung. Oder du meinst
so Themengebiete, die man
sich anschauen sollte. Nicht Studium, sondern
die man sich anschauen sollte. Wenn er
Netzwerkarchitekt werden will,
ja gut. Ich würde sagen, es wäre ganz
gut, wenn du dich mit Netzwerktechnik
auskennst. Wenn du dich
natürlich auch mit den Sachen drumherum, also
Security, Linux nicht
verkehrt. Ganz viele Kisten von
Cisco sind ja heute auch ganz normal
x86
Dinger. Teilweise glaube ich
sogar auf Linux-Basis, wenn ich
nicht täusche.
Aber Netzwerkarchitektur,
da musst du schon,
musst du halt auch gucken, in welchem Bereich. Ich meine,
das ist ein Unterschied, ob man klassisch,
lokal, vor Ort
oder ob man noch zusätzlich
irgendwelche
Cloud-Anbieter anbinden muss.
Und dort dann auch schauen, okay,
wie funktioniert das da? Wie kann
ich von den Kisten vor Ort
on-prem, wie das die coolen Leute nennen,
zugreifen auf alle Cloud-Services
oder teilweise wie Cloud-Services vereinzelt
auf manche lokalen Kisten zugreifen.
Du musst dich recht breit auskennen,
würde ich sagen. Ansonsten, keine Ahnung,
ich bin kein Netzwerkarchitekt.
Max, würdest du, wenn du nach
Berufserfahrung gefragt wirst, nach Jahren die Anzahl
von der Ausbildung mit
aufzählen? Also, normalerweise
sagt man ja, nee, Ausbildung
ist keine Berufserfahrung.
Ich persönlich würde das nicht so eng sehen.
Ich finde das nicht schlimm.
Wenn man sagt, hey, ich beschäftige mich,
keine Ahnung, seit 2005.
Ich bin seit 2005 in der Branche.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich habe es in meinem Bewerbungsgespräch
so gesagt.
Ungefähr so, wie ich es jetzt gesagt habe.
Ich beschäftige mich da schon
professionell seit 2005 mit.
Erst die Ausbildung
beim Internet-Provider,
dann das und das und das.
Und da ging ganz klar daraus hervor, dass ich die
Ausbildungssachen mitgezählt habe.
Und in deinem Lebenslauf
schreibst du ja eh rein.
Die Station, was du gemacht hast.
Und da geht das ja daraus hervor.
Wenn es jetzt natürlich
eine Stelle gibt,
wo drauf steht, wir möchten
mindestens 5 Jahre
plus
Erfahrung so und so,
dann kannst du die Ausbildung nicht mit
rechnen dafür.
Das ist denen dann wurscht.
Weil dann hast du ja quasi 3 Jahre Ausbildung,
oder je nachdem, wie lange du gebraucht hast,
plus 2.
Dann wollen die wirklich 5 Jahre nach der Ausbildung haben.
Aber da gibt es
erstaunlich wenig Stellen, wo eine konkrete
Jahresanzahl
drin steht.
Was ich öfters gesehen habe, ist so
vielleicht was im Bereich von 2 Jahren oder so.
Wo dann steht, 2 Jahre
plus Java, Enterprise,
Business, Erfahrung und so was.
Aber umso länger es wird,
man sieht, wir gucken uns ja hier
öfters mal Stellenanzeigen an, sieht man
eigentlich verhältnismäßig wenig,
darüber hinausgehend, was steht.
Also manchmal steht da halt
ganz abgedrehtes Zeug drin.
Wir hatten auch schon mal ganz vereinzelt so
Dinger wie 7 Jahre mindestens
in dem und dem.
Und dann wollen sie am Ende
34k bezahlen oder so.
Ja.
Also.
Es steht tatsächlich,
also es steht meistens nicht so
konkret drin. Es steht meistens
irgendwie einschlägige mehrjährige
Berufserfahrung in dem
und dem Gebiet.
Man kann da
sicherlich 5 Jahre
reinlesen.
Aber ja.
Ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen, viele Unternehmen sind
heute auch ein bisschen flexibler
bei der Auswahl der Leute.
Wenn die sagen, sie suchen jetzt jemand als
Senior Java Entwickler
und schreiben
rein, mehrjährige
Erfahrung
im Java-Business, was auch immer,
Enterprise, irgendwas, Bereich.
Und
du kommst dann an und
sagst, ja, ich hab 4 Jahre Erfahrung
und die haben sich jemand vorgestellt,
der 5 Jahre Erfahrung hat.
Aber wenn du einen guten Eindruck machst und die können
heute eh nicht so wählerisch sein, weil die schlicht
und ergreifend keine Leute finden, dann kommst
du damit trotzdem, geht das trotzdem.
Deswegen haben vielleicht auch so viele,
drücken sich da vor, tatsächlich
konkrete
Jahres
Zeiträume
reinzuschreiben.
10 Jahre Kubernetes-Erfahrung, wobei ich glaube,
das geht mittlerweile sogar
ganz knapp, oder?
Ja, okay, fast, fast.
Ab nächstem,
okay, wenn du bei der
Kubernetes-Alpha-Phase schon
dabei warst, dann könntest
du 10 Jahre Berufserfahrung haben.
Falls es da sowas gab.
Early-Access, wenn du Kubernetes-Early-Access
mitgemacht hast, dann kannst
du 10 Jahre Berufserfahrung haben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, richtig. Das steht meistens
gar nicht so konkret drinnen.
Oh ja, gucken wir mal weiter, was macht denn das
iPhone 15?
Bro!
...testet und wurde mehr als nur einmal
überrascht. Positiv, aber auch negativ.
Wow, Alter, mach nicht so laut!
Ey,
die Kühle, jetzt übertreiben sie aber wieder.
...tausend Apple-Designer haben
ein ganzes Jahr am Design des
neuen iPhone... Tausend Apple-Designer?
Da wundert mich nichts mehr.
Wie soll denn ein Gerät von
tausend Designern gleichzeitig
designt werden können?
Wie soll man sich das vorstellen?
Ah, okay, ich bin
Designer 714.
Ich bin für das
untere
Zwanzigstel der linken Seite
...gearbeitet und das Ergebnis
sieht aus wie ein iPhone 14 Pro,
das aussah wie ein 13 Pro,
das aussah wie ein 12 Pro,
das aussah wie ein 11 Pro.
Gab es nicht im Vorfeld die Gerüchte,
dass die Kameras noch weiter rausstehen?
Wie das iPhone aussieht
und wie es sich anfühlt, sind dieses Jahr
zwei komplett verschiedene Welten.
Ist doch auch so, oder?
Der Rahmen ist etwas runder
und deswegen wirkt das Gerät
erstaunlich viel dünner und ergonomischer.
Man versteht das echt erst,
wenn man es mal selbst in der Hand hatte.
Außerdem besteht der Rahmen aus Titan,
ein Material, das leichter und gleichzeitig
fester ist als Edelstahl.
Auf dem gebürsteten Titan gibt es
weniger Kratzer, Dellen oder ganz einfach Schmutz.
Immer noch genauso anfällig
für Schmutz und Staub ist ...
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich habe mein iPhone eh nur in der Hülle,
weil du kannst ohne Hülle
das Ding ja nicht mehr gescheit
auf den Tisch legen, wegen dieser
stehenden Kamerawulst hier.
Man muss das eigentlich
in die Hülle packen,
sodass es noch halbwegs
flach auf dem Tisch liegen kann.
Oder halbwegs ohne die ganze Zeit zu wackeln
auf dem Tisch liegen kann.
Gerade, dass du auch mal was gucken kannst.
Und dementsprechend
hatte ich noch nie
irgendwelche Probleme
mit Kratzern
oder Beschädigungen
an der Hülle.
Eigentlich eine iPhone-Hülle.
Ein Case.
Wieder das Kamera-Element.
Die Linsen stehen deutlich
weiter heraus als bei jedem
aktuellen Smartphone und das ist einfach
ungünstig im Fall eines Sturzes.
Ich hatte irgendwie gehofft, dass Apple mal
ein neues Design wagt. Immer wieder dasselbe
ist zwar gut für den Wiedererkennungswert einer Marke,
aber ... Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde,
das sieht mega kacke aus.
Dieses Kamera-Element hier oben.
Das ist jetzt nichts Neues. Ich finde,
das sieht seit Jahren schon kacke aus.
Und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen,
ich finde nicht, dass es die anderen Hersteller
sondern ich viel hübscher hinkriegen.
Aber ich finde nach wie vor, dass es kacke aussieht.
Auf der anderen Seite,
du hast wahrscheinlich gar keine
Wahl, wenn du Kameras
haben möchtest mit all diesen Funktionen.
Im Zweifelsfall auch mit
Teleobjektiv und Zoom
und hast du nicht gesehen.
Die brauchen halt einfach eine gewisse Größe,
Öffnung und Tiefe, dass es funktioniert.
Insofern,
das ist doch schon lange so.
Ganz ehrlich, es gibt doch sogar
Studien mittlerweile,
dass
Hersteller, nennen wir es mal
Gläubigkeit,
für Leute Religionsersatz
heutzutage ist.
Sei es jetzt Apple
oder auch die alte Story
PlayStation vs. Vixbox
Nein, Gaystation vs. Vixbox
war das damals noch.
Da gibt es sogar Studien zu,
dass so,
wie nennt man das so,
Herstellerverehrung
für Leute heutzutage Religionsersatz ist.
Also das ist nicht erst seit gestern so.
Und Apple
zelebriert das schon jahrelang.
Was?
Seriously?
Man kann iPhones neuerdings
gescheit reparieren?
Das Glas, okay.
Ja, okay, nur das Glas.
Übers Jahr?
Moment, es ist nicht, dass es übers Jahr
leichter wird.
7kg pro Jahr?
Also ich mein,
man kann alles irgendwie rechnen,
aber ich find, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, es ist 19g leichter.
Oder es ist immer 19g leichter.
Das ist auch übers Jahr
19g leichter.
Wie viel leichter ist es denn pro 24 Stunden?
Und jetzt, wo war ich?
Ja, Wasserfestigkeit,
30 Minuten, 6 Meter Tiefe,
mehr als Google, Xiaomi und Samsung zusammen.
Ach, und bei Freenet bedanken.
Bei Freenet bekommt ihr einfach alles.
Freenet? Ja, ganz richtig.
Einfach alles. Mobilfunk, Internet,
TV-Entertainment und ihr könnt auswählen.
Ist das nicht auch
United Internet?
Also quasi
1&1?
Ja, ist das doch.
Ja.
Apropos schwarze Fläche, oben ist ein langes Loch im Display, da drin steckt nicht nur
die Selfie-Kamera, sondern auch Face-ID.
Das ist eine schnelle, zuverlässige Gesichtserkennung, die mich immer erkennt, außer, wenn ich an
die Sonnenbrille blicke.
Moment, das hat ja nicht nur das 15er, das haben die alten ja auch schon.
Was dieses Loch da oben aber auch ist, ist ein adaptives Widget.
Dynamic Island nennt das Apple und obwohl ich es nicht cool finde, ist die Nutzung im
Alltag eher sporadisch.
Ganz ehrlich, das hat meins auch.
Ich benutze es nie.
Ich finde es vor allem praktisch, jederzeit schnell zu meiner Musik-Wiedergabe oder der
Navigation zurückspringen zu können.
Die Animationen sehen einfach schick aus und es macht natürlich total Sinn, dass man da
oben direkt Anrufe bekommt oder über den Fortschritt eines Airdrops informiert wird.
Im iPhone 15 Pro steckt der A17 Pro und das ist der weltweit erste 3-Nanometer-Prozessor.
Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich?
Es bedeutet, dass auf selber Fläche mehr Transistoren passen und das bedeutet bessere
Performance und bessere Effizienz.
Apple spricht von 10% mehr CPU und 20% mehr GPU-Performance.
Die CPU ist in Geekbench 6 rund 40% schneller als der Snapdragon 8 Gen 2.
Das ist der aktuell schnellste...
Ich mein, das muss man Apple mal lassen.
Die Dinger sind schon geil, was sie da bauen.
Apple kann natürlich aber auch ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste, was Preis angeht, da ihre CPUs
raushauen.
Also ich mein, was das kostet, ist halt nicht mehr feierlich.
Aber trotzdem, das ist schon nicht schlecht, was sie da auf die Beine gestellt haben die
letzten Jahre über.
Trotzdem wird man es wahrscheinlich kaum spüren im normalen Alltag bei der Benutzung
zwischen dem 16er und dem 17er und diese offiziellen Benchmarks sind ja eh immer ein bisschen vor
sich zu genießen.
Schnellste Android-Prozessor und die GPU etwa 7%.
Im 3D-Mark-Stresstest drosselte der A17 Pro jedoch flott um 30% und nach etwa 20 Minuten
um 50% herunter.
Das ist etwas schade zu sehen, auch wenn die Leistung selbst dann noch höher ist als
von einem Pixel 7 Pro ohne Drosselung.
Im Alltag ist die Performance vom iPhone 14 Pro nicht zu unterscheiden, das war auch schon
ultraschnell und flüssig.
Aber dieses Mal gibt es iPhone 15 Pro exklusive Spiele und nicht einfach irgendwelche.
Richtige Konsolentitel wie Resident Evil Village, Assassin's Creed Mirage oder ja als würde
das auf dem 14er nicht funktionieren oder The Division Resurgence und die haben eine
ernsthaft beeindruckende Grafik inklusive Raytracing-Lichteffekten, aber und das ist
ein großes Aber.
Boah, wie ich so keinen Bock hätte, das auf dem Display zu spielen, Alter, guck dich das
mal an, ein Controller auf dem Display, oh das ist ja ergonomisch und benutzt, oh das
ist ja grausam, ey, wer zum, Alter, wer will denn sowas spielen?
Laufen nicht mal ansatzweise in nativer Display-Auflösung und man ist praktisch gezwungen, ein Gamepad
zu benutzen, weil sonst die Hälfte vom Bild von der Steuerung verdeckt wird.
Ja und man es nicht gescheit benutzen kann.
Okay, positiv aufgefallen sind mir mal wieder die Stereo-Lautsprecher.
Was der A17 Pro leider nicht hat, ist ein H2-Chip, wie er in der Vision Pro und in den
neuen AirPods Pro steckt, der ermöglicht eine geringere Latenz und ist einfach zukunftssicherer.
Und apropos langlebig, das iPhone wird extrem lange Software-Updates bekommen, wie lange
genau weiß niemand, man geht aber von so 6 Jahren aus, das wäre dann noch bis iOS
23.
Aber jetzt haben wir erst mal iOS 17 und ein paar nette neue Funktionen.
Das ist ja tatsächlich bei Apple ganz gut.
Ich glaube, du hast im Android-Bereich mittlerweile auch ein paar Sachen, gerade die offiziellen
von Google, die recht lange Updates kriegen, aber das macht Apple schon seit, man muss
ja mittlerweile sagen, Jahrzehnten, echt ganz gut, was die Langlebigkeit der Dinger
angeht.
Man kann den Sperrbildschirm feiner anpassen, AirDrop hat eine coole neue Animation, wenn
man zwei iPhones aneinander hält und Budgets sind jetzt interaktiv, was mich sehr freut.
Man kann aus jedem Foto jetzt einen Sticker machen und es gibt ein Standby-Display, wenn
das iPhone auflädt.
Viele, viele kleine neue Funktionen und ganz allgemein schätze ich an iOS, wie einheitlich
es aussieht und die ganzen schönen verspielten Animationen.
Es ist nicht perfekt.
Ja, die Autokorrektur der Tastatur ist trotz neuer künstlicher Intelligenz gefühlt immer
noch hundertmal dümmer, als die von Google und auch das Nachrichtensystem ist…
Ich verstehe das mit dem Auto korrekt nicht.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, mit dem iPhone… gab es mal ein iPhone 4S oder sowas?
Ach, danke für den Host, Pog.
Ähm, hallo Leute.
Oder es ist ja kein Host mehr, es ist ja ein Raid mittlerweile auf Twitch.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen, gab es mal ein iPhone 4S?
Oder war das ein iPhone 6S?
Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht genau.
4S?
Das, wo ich diese Super Mario Ghost Hülle drum hatte.
Ja, also genau, noch das mit dem Knopf.
Das mit dem Knopf noch.
Und ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, dass die Autokorrektur damals nicht so beschissen
war wie heute.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das auf die Reihe kriegt, das so zu verschlimmbessern.
Vielleicht liegt es auch daran, dass ich mittlerweile Englisch eingestellt habe, also
Englisch-OS-Sprache und aber deutsches Keyboard-Dings, woran erkennt, dass man Deutsch tippt.
Aber ich hatte den Eindruck, dass es besser funktioniert hat, der Autokorrektur auf dem
4S damals, beziehungsweise den älteren, wie auf den neuen.
Was eigentlich überhaupt nicht sein kann.
Es ergibt ja normalerweise keinen Sinn.
Du würdest eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass solche Sachen nicht schlechter werden über
die Jahre, sondern immer besser.
Vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur mein Eindruck, der falsch ist.
Ich habe auch richtige Autokorrektur-Probleme mit dem iPhone.
Der korrigiert den übelsten Blödsinn.
Wobei, es ist nicht alles gut.
Die blödsinnigste Korrektur, die ich jemals hatte, auf dem alten iPhone war, erinnert
sich noch jemand?
In Call of Duty gab es einen Killstreak, der sich Juggernaut nannte.
Hier, sowas.
Das war so ein Anzug, den man bekommen hat und dann hat man mehr ausgehalten.
Ich wollte damals irgendeinen Tweet schreiben, wo das Wort Juggernaut drin vorkam.
Wisst ihr, was meine Apple-Autokorrektur aus dem Wort Juggernaut gemacht hat?
Könnt ihr nicht wissen, weil wahrscheinlich hat das damals keiner gelesen auf Twitter.
Jungfernhäutchen.
Moment, das geht jetzt aber in die ganz falsche Richtung, Apple-Autokorrektur.
Ich habe dann gesagt, nein, nein, nein, ich will schon das andere Wort haben.
Ja, das war ein ziemlicher Fail.
Gibt es denn jetzt sonst noch irgendwas Neues, Tolles beim iPhone 15 Pro, das ich unbedingt
haben will?
Bis jetzt habe ich nämlich noch nichts gesehen.
Oh, guck mal, der hat auch einen Roborock S7.
Ich glaube, das waren die letzten, die man halbwegs gescheit flashen konnte.
Ganz davon abgesehen, ich habe ja meinen Staubsauger-Roboter auch wieder ausgemustert.
Gucken wir mal, ob noch irgendwas kommt.
Moment, bei was?
Moment, Moment, bei was lässt Apple mehr zu?
Okay.
Okay, kann man jetzt darüber diskutieren, was er meint mit Anpassungsfähigkeiten, aber
da würde ich sagen, nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Also was Automatisierung angeht, ist Android einfach meilenweit immer noch vor iOS.
Ich meine, du hast mittlerweile auf iOS, sie haben es ja umbenannt mittlerweile, in Siri-Shortcuts.
Also wenn es um Tasks und Ablaufautomatisierung geht und sowas, da kannst du seit Jahren ja
beispielsweise Tasker mit seinen 1000 Plugins verwenden auf Android und Siri-Shortcuts,
ich glaube, oder heißt es mittlerweile nur noch Shortcuts?
Keine Ahnung, aber diese Sache, die sie mal aufgekauft haben, was früher, glaube ich,
Workflowy hieß und dann irgendwann Shortcuts und jetzt mittlerweile Siri-Shortcuts.
Also das ist ja okay, das geht alles.
Halbwegs klar, sofern die Funktion eingebaut ist.
Aber du kannst sehr vieles schlicht und ergreifend nicht machen mit Shortcuts, was du mit Tasker
machen kannst.
Ja, du kannst mit Tasker beispielsweise nahezu alles in deinem OS in irgendeiner Art und Weise
ansteuern.
Ja, du kannst Settings umstellen, du kannst, ich glaube, Displayhelligkeit kannst du auch
machen mit Shortcuts.
Du kannst im Hintergrund ausführen, was ja unter iOS prinzipiell so ohne weiteres gar
nicht möglich ist.
Du kannst ein Plugin installieren, dass das an einem MQTT-Server lauscht, daraufhin dann
das Display entsperrt und sowas.
Keine Chance, das zu machen unter iOS und keine Chance bzw. keine Hoffnung, die ich
da irgendwie sehe, dass das jemals unter iOS möglich ist.
Das ist nicht schlimm in dem Sinn.
Man muss halt einfach nur wissen, wo die Stärken des jeweiligen Systems liegen.
Also ich bin der Meinung, wenn es um Automatisierung und Customization geht, ist Android einfach
das Beste.
Deswegen habe ich auch meine Heimautomatisierung-Tablets, sind Android-Tablets.
Also ich habe so Dashboards an der Wand, wo man dann angucken kann, wie weit ist das Auto
geladen oder Rollladen runter machen oder checken, ob noch irgendwo ein Fenster auf ist und sowas.
Das habe ich auf Android-Basis.
Da kann man dann zum Beispiel so Dinge machen wie lausche an einem MQTT-Server und wenn
du eine Message bekommst, dann spiele eine Message, dann spiele einen Sound ab oder ich
kann ansteuern, abends die Displayhelligkeit runter, tagsüber die Displayhelligkeit hoch
und das alles remote.
Das wird man so mit einem iPhone bzw. auch mit einem iPad in der Variante.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Das kannst du komplett knicken.
Das ist einfach nicht möglich.
Für tägliche Nutzung ist mir persönlich ein iPhone auch lieber.
Also man muss einfach gucken, wo die Stärken der jeweiligen Systeme liegen.
So dieses ultra-religiöse Gefanboy hat eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, wird mal wieder Zeit, wobei sich da nicht so viel geändert hat.
Als nächstes muss ich erstmal das Video machen, was ich seit Monaten schon angekündigt habe,
nämlich meine, ich wollte euch ja meinen Lebenslauf und meine Bewerbung zeigen.
Überlegst du dir das neue iPhone zu kaufen?
Nee.
Ich habe einen 14 Pro, das reicht mir.
Ich muss ja nicht unbedingt jedes Jahr, jede eineinhalb Jahre Apple 1,5K oder so überweisen.
Ich meine, an Amazon ist okay.
Ich meine, Bezos muss ins Weltall fliegen, mal wieder.
Dem überweise ich Geld, aber an Apple muss ich kein Geld überweisen.
Actionknopf ist ein super Beispiel dafür.
Seit dem ersten iPhone gab es an der Seite einen Schalter, mit dem man zwischen laut
und lautlos umschalten konnte.
Der ist jetzt weg.
Warum?
Und an seiner Stelle ein Knopf.
Den kann man frei belegen.
Man kann ihn zum Beispiel gedrückt halten.
Das finde ich eine ganz coole Sache.
Das finde ich tatsächlich nice.
Das ist die erste Funktion, ohne Scheiß jetzt in dem ganzen Video, die erste Funktion,
wo ich sagen würde, okay, das ist was, wo ich mir denke, ja, das hätte ich gern.
Aber das reicht für mich nicht, dafür jetzt ein neues iPhone zu kaufen.
Weil ich habe mein iPhone immer grundsätzlich lautlos.
Und wenn ich das mal alle Schaltjahre nicht lautlos haben will, dann hätte ich kein Problem,
das in irgendeinem On-Screen-Settings-Menü umzustellen.
Touchscreen-Settings-Menü.
Genau die tausend Designer haben an dem Menü hier gearbeitet.
Also das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Um weiterhin den Lautlos-Modus zu aktivieren.
Oder jetzt eben die Taschenlampe.
Oder man wechselt zwischen Hintergrundbildern.
Oder man startet den Google Assistant.
Wisst ihr, was noch cooler wäre?
Wenn man Short-Press und Long-Press unterschiedlich konfigurieren kann.
Ob da die tausend Designer dran gedacht haben, was meint ihr?
Meint ihr, man könnte vielleicht sogar Double-Click anders konfigurieren wie Single-Press und so?
Ich meine, das wäre natürlich noch cooler.
Wenn du Single-Click, Double-Click und Long-Press machen könntest.
Das kommt erst nächstes Jahr.
Ja, stimmt. Irgendwas brauchst du für nächstes Jahr ja auch noch.
Also ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Dass sie da auch dran gedacht haben.
... Siri an der Backe hat.
Sekunde.
Das Menü, in dem man die Funktionen wechseln kann, sieht ziemlich spektakulär,
aber auch irgendwie untypisch für Apple aus.
Ich finde den Action-Knopf eine super Sache, würde mir aber wünschen, dass er geriffelt wäre,
damit ich ihn besser von der Lautstärkewippe unterscheiden kann.
Ich persönlich nutze ihn für die Kamera, weil man dann direkt mit ihm auch Fotos und Videos aufnehmen kann.
Und das ist doch ein guter Zeitpunkt, um über die Kamera zu sprechen, oder?
Drei Linsen gibt es.
Ein 12 Megapixel-Ultraweitwinkel mit Autofokus,
ein großer 48 Megapixel-Hauptsensor
und eine 12-fach-Tele.
Alles also so wie letztes Jahr, aber es gibt ein paar Neuerungen, die für bessere Fotos sorgen.
Erstens.
Bilder werden nicht mehr standardmäßig in 12, sondern in 24 Megapixel gemacht.
Also auf den meisten Seiten, wo die Leute Bilder posten und das auf kleinem Vorschau sehen,
wirst du das nicht merken.
Zum Bearbeiten, wobei bearbeiten kann man die auch irgendwie RAW speichern oder so.
Wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer Fotobearbeiter, keine Ahnung.
Das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Ob das defaultmäßig so sinnvoll ist?
Ja gut, doch, für Apple ist das defaultmäßig sinnvoll.
Da können sie nämlich dir ultra teure Speicherupgrades verkaufen bei einem iPhone.
Es ist unglaublich, was Speicherupgrades kosten.
Das kostet hunderte Euro.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 100 Gigabyte mehr speichern in so einem iPhone.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 150 Euro mehr oder sowas.
Das ist mega teuer.
Dafür kriegst du quasi schon Terabyte-SSD.
Das ist unsinnig, unverhältnismäßig teuer, was Speicherbestückungen bei Smartphones generell kosten.
Die sind nur 0,2 bis 1 Megabyte größer und auf keinen Fall doppelt so scharf, wie man das vermuten würde.
Aber schon so 5 bis vielleicht 10 Prozent.
Im neuen Hive Max Modus sind die Fotos etwa doppelt so groß, dann aber auch deutlich schärfer, weil es die vollen 48 Megapixel sind.
Das ist mein Lieblingsmodus.
Im Vergleich zum 200 Megapixel Galaxy S23 Ultra sieht man dann aber, dass das iPhone 15 Pro weniger scharf ist und gleichzeitig künstlich nachschärft.
Zweitens, der Nacht- und der Porträtmodus nutzen jetzt auch die Photonic Engine.
Als wenn ich jetzt demnächst mein Fahrrad fotografiere und es schärfer aussieht, dann ist es gar nicht mehr wirklich mein Fahrrad, was ich fotografiert habe, sondern ein AI-enhanced Bild von meinem Fahrrad.
Künstlich nachschärft.
Zweitens, der Nacht- und der Porträtmodus nutzen jetzt auch die Photonic Engine.
Das ist ein komplizierter Name, der im Endeffekt bedeutet, es sind hellere, schärfere Fotos und das finde ich super.
Drittens, bei jedem Foto wird jetzt die Tiefeninfo gespeichert, das heißt man kann auch im Nachhinein den Porträt-Effekt auswählen und sowohl die Stärke als auch den Fokuspunkt steuern.
Okay, das ist cool. Das ist nice. Das wird aber wahrscheinlich auch mit dem alten iPhone funktionieren.
Das ist ein Feature, das es beim Google Pixel schon seit 6 Jahren gibt, aber ich bin nicht nachtragend. Es ist jetzt da, Apple hat es jetzt auch und ich finde es praktisch.
Viertens, man kann jetzt neben 24mm auch in 8...
Hast du dir schon ein Fahrrad gekauft? Ja, ich habe mir ein Fahrrad gekauft, aber das kommt erst am Montag.
...28 und 35mm Brennweite fotografieren. Letztere ist genau ein 24 Megapixel Ausschnitt vom Sensor...
Welches? Okay, okay. Sack. Sack, Leute.
Ähm, ich habe es hier glaube ich noch auf... Moment. Oh, fuck. Ich habe zu viel... Ah, das da.
Habe ich mir gekauft, in blau. Fun Move, genau. Das da.
Dürft ihr einmal eine Runde über den Preis kecken? Und jetzt mache ich wieder zu. Richtiger Schnapper war das, ja.
Total gerne. Auch bei meiner richtigen Kamera fotografiere ich am liebsten mit einem 35mm Objektiv.
Fünftens, es gibt eine neue 5-Fach-Telekamera, allerdings nur im 15 Pro Max und die hat einen 25% größeren 12 Megapixel-Sensor und dieselbe f2.8-Blende wie die 3-Fach-Kamera.
Ich habe die 3-Fach- und die 5-Fach-Tele viel miteinander verglichen und bei 3-Fach ist das iPhone 15 Pro natürlich deutlich schärfer als das 15 Pro Max.
Äh, warum natürlich? Ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst. Warum ist das Pro natürlich so viel schärfer als das 15 Pro Max?
Ich hatte gedacht, da sind exakt die gleichen Kameras drin. Ich habe jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht richtig aufgepasst, aber warum?
Chat-Gewerde aufgepasst. Ich habe nicht richtig zugehört.
Ich habe die 3-Fach- und die 5-Fach-Tele viel miteinander verglichen und bei 3-Fach ist das iPhone 15 Pro natürlich deutlich schärfer als das 15 Pro Max.
Warum? Das sind die gleichen Kameras. Warum ist da so ein Unterschied?
Ah, nee, hä? Moment, das Pro ist größer, hat eine schlechte Kamera, schlechter als das 15er?
Warum hat das Pro... hä? Okay, das ist Apple-Logik, das muss ich nicht checken.
Aber warum ist der 5-Fach-optische Zoom pixeliger als der 3-Fach-optische Zoom bei... hä?
Egal, ich gucke jetzt einfach weiter.
Bei 4,9-Fach im Zoom erst recht, aber bei 5-Fach ist dann natürlich das Pro Max schärfer, aber gar nicht so viel wie ich erwartet habe.
Ach so, okay, okay, okay. Ah, okay, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Der hat, der hat bei dem einen, was ein 3-Fach... okay, das eine hat einen 5-Fachen-Zoom, das andere hat einen 3-Fachen-Zoom.
Der hat quasi auf theoretisch 3-Fach gestellt und bei dem anderen...
Jetzt hat er die Native-Auflösung mit dem Fake-3-Fach verglichen und hier die Native-5-Fach mit dem Fake-5-Fach.
Jetzt habe ich es, glaube ich, kapiert, ja.
Also gerade hier an den Fenstern erkennt man schon, dass es ein ganz schöner Unterschied ist.
Das 15 Pro kann erstaunlich gut mithalten, selbst wenn man 10-Fach zoomt.
Klar, das 15 Pro Max ist zweifellos besser, aber ich hätte etwas mehr erwartet.
Eine Erklärung könnte sein, dass die neue Objektiv-Technik etwas weniger scharf ist.
Hier auch mal neben dem Pixel 7 Pro bei 5-Fach und 10-Fach neben dem Galaxy S23 Ultra.
Meine größte Kritik an der iPhone 15 Pro Kamera ist die Naheinstellgrenze der 5-Fach-Tele und der Hauptkamera.
Man muss unverhältnismäßig weit weg sein, damit das Motiv scharf wird.
Sehr, sehr oft wechselt das iPhone auf die Ultra-Weitwinkel-Kamera und die ist qualitativ deutlich schlechter als die Hauptkamera.
Ich meine, schaut euch an, was für einen Unterschied das in einem Foto machen kann, wenn die Naheinstellgrenze gut ist.
Das ist das Xiaomi 13 Pro mit Leica...
Okay, das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, okay, Hauptsache es funktioniert irgendwie, ohne dass ich manuell irgendwas machen muss,
weil das ist mir viel zu pfeiffert, mich damit zu beschäftigen, bevor ich irgendwie mal schnell meine Katze fotografiere oder so.
Linse und die Fotos dort sehen aus wie aus einer richtigen Kamera.
Was die Farbwiedergabe, Hauttöne und den Dynamikumfang angeht, macht Apple einen extrem guten Job.
Die iPhone-Bilder sind von zu hellen Mitten abgesehen, verlässlich schön, egal mit welcher Brennweite man fotografiert.
Da werden absolute Amateure, aber auch professionelle Fotografen ihre Freude mithaben.
Der große 48 Megapixel Hauptsensor und der Makro-Ultra-Weitwinkel sind meine Highlights.
Das iPhone 15 Pro unterstützt jetzt 4K 60fps ProRes-Videos, allerdings nur über USB-C auf eine externe SSD.
Außerdem wird er...
Leute, hat das jetzt irgendeinen Sinn, dass er gerade die Treppe runterläuft?
...Ultra-Weitwinkel sind meine Highlights.
Das iPhone 15 Pro unterstützt...
Das ist einfach nur, dass ich das besser im Video flowe, oder?
Es hat jetzt keinen Zusammenhang zum iPhone, dass er da die Treppe runterläuft, oder?
Das ist jetzt 4K 60fps ProRes-Videos, allerdings nur über USB-C auf eine externe SSD.
Außerdem wird ein Log-Farbprofil unterstützt...
Wait a minute, habe ich da was von externe SSD verstanden?
Moment, Moment, Moment, nochmal.
Das iPhone 15 Pro unterstützt jetzt 4K 60fps ProRes-Videos, allerdings nur über USB-C auf eine externe SSD.
Ah, achso, man kann quasi eine externe SSD über USB anschließen, wo das dann die Videos draufspeichern.
Ja, ja okay, finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Außerdem wird ein Log-Farbprofil unterstützt, das ermöglicht umfangreicheres Color-Grading.
Nur eine Sache ist mir ganz wichtig zu betonen.
Anders als das Apple in ihrer Werbung mehrfach behauptet, kann das iPhone selbstverständlich keine Kinokamera ersetzen.
Apple erzählt so einen Stoß.
Wisst ihr, eines der besten Sachen war immer noch auf einem der letzten...
Ach, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo sie die Apple Watch angekündigt haben?
Wo dann die Apple Watch der schwangeren Frau gesagt hat, dass sie jetzt mal ins Krankenhaus muss, weil ihr Kind auf die Welt kommt.
Wo ich mir so gedacht habe, Moment, ich dachte, das merkt man eigentlich.
Ist jetzt nicht so, als bräuchte ich da meine Apple Watch für.
Also ich eh nicht, aber...
Ich dachte eigentlich...
Vor allem fragt man sich, wie haben die Leute das früher hinbekommen?
Die hätten das ja fast verpasst.
Ohne Apple Watch.
So hoch?
Wo kommt denn das jetzt so auf einmal her?
Ha, ich hab keine Apple Watch, dann hätte ich meine Apple Watch gehabt.
Auf einmal ist es da?
Hätte ja keiner wissen können.
Also die haben teilweise auf ihren Präsentationen schon ein bisschen merkwürdiges Zeug.
Wobei das immer noch...
Also der...
Der sinnloseste Teil, also der größte Bullshit-Teil für mich...
In einem von...
Sei es jetzt Apple, Microsoft, Gaming...
Ankündigung der letzten Jahre war immer noch die Windows 11 Präsentation.
Die Windows 11 Präsentation...
Wo...
Wo nichts gezeigt...
Also die ganze Windows 11 Präsentation war ziemlich ja Müll.
Aber...
Dieser eine Part...
Wo eigentlich nichts gezeigt wurde...
Aber wo eine erzählt hat...
Dass für sie Windows gleich Family ist.
Da musste ich so hart cringen wie selten bei irgend so einer Präsentation.
Könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern?
Das war eine Frau, die hat erzählt...
Dass sie mit Windows so schöne Kindheitserinnerungen verbindet.
Und für sie ist Windows Family.
Und sie muss immer dran denken an ihren...
Keine Ahnung...
Verstorbenen Vater und so.
Wenn sie Windows benutzt.
Und das ist so emotional.
Und alles...
Wo du so denkst, gleich heult noch einer in der Präsentation.
Gut.
Der Windows 11 Präsentator hat eh ausgesehen, als fängt er gleich an zu weinen.
Ich mein...
Guckt euch den mal an.
Der war eh...
Der...
Er hier.
Wo ist er denn?
Event.
Ah da muss man wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich...
Er hier.
Der sieht einfach so aus, als weint er gleich.
Guck mal.
Der sieht eigentlich so heute gleich alter.
Das ist grausam.
Also das war wirklich...
Das war echt alles der schlimmsten Präsentation, die ich da in den letzten Jahren über gesehen hab.
Hab ich ganz vergessen, wo wir hier stehen geblieben sind.
Okay.
Lass uns mal kurz das iPhone Video fertig gucken.
Es ist mit Abstand das beste Smartphone zum Filmen und mit den ganzen neuen Features...
Er muss auch jeden Tag mit Windows arbeiten, da kann er weinen, ja hast recht.
Es ist dieser Abstand nur noch größer geworden.
Das iPhone 15 Pro hat einen 2% größeren Akku und einen 3nm Prozessor.
Ich hab deswegen eine deutlich verbesserte Akkulaufzeit erwartet, aber leider nicht bekommen.
Die Laufzeit ist sehr ähnlich zum Vorgänger.
Ich hab vor allem das 15 Pro Max genutzt und dort waren es etwa 5,5 bis 6,5 Stunden Displaynutzung, bis der Akku leer war.
Wenn man aber nur im WLAN und im Dunkelmodus ist, gehen nochmal 1 bis 2 Stunden mehr.
Das normale 15 Pro hält etwa 1 bis 2 Stunden weniger.
Keine Rekord-Akku-Laufzeit, aber sie ist auf einem guten Level und vergleichbar mit dem Galaxy S23 Ultra oder Honor Magic 5 Pro.
Aufgeladen wird jetzt endlich nicht mehr über Lightning, sondern USB-C.
Ja, die EU hat Apple regelrecht gezwungen und was soll ich sagen...
Aber wirklich, die haben das ja wirklich ausgereizt bis zum letzten, dass sie das jetzt machen.
Ich bin dankbar dafür. Es fühlt sich immer noch etwas surreal an, ein USB-C-Kabel in das iPhone zu stecken, aber es ist ein wahrer Segen.
Ich kann mein MacBook, ein Android-Smartphone, iPads und alle anderen Tablets, meine Waage und Akkuschrauber...
Leute, die Zukunft... Moment, sein Akkuschrauber!
...ein USB-C-Kabel in das iPhone zu stecken, aber es ist ein wahrer Segen.
Ich kann mein MacBook, ein Android-Smartphone, iPads und alle anderen Tablets, meine Waage und Akkuschrauber...
Achso, das geht bei mir nicht als Akkuschrauber durch.
...und das iPhone jetzt auch mit ein und demselben Kabel aufladen.
Das beiliegende USB-C-Kabel ist außerdem schön hochwertig mit Stoff umhüllt.
Alle Lightning-Produkte funktionieren weiterhin, wenn man einen 29-Euro-Adapter kauft.
Ja, typisch...
Apple, was sonst?
Ich hatte gehofft, dass USB-C bedeuten würde, dass wir endlich auch Schnellladen ins iPhone bekommen, aber das ist leider nicht der Fall.
Während aktuelle Android-Smartphones in 20-30 Minuten vollständig laden können und dabei doppelt so langlebige Akkutechnik verwenden wie das iPhone, dauert es beim iPhone eine ganze Stunde länger.
Aber ich bin ein Fan von MagSafe.
Dann kauf ich mir lieber den China-Chinesen-Adapter dafür, der kostet wahrscheinlich 2,50 Euro.
Aber gut, da haben dann auch nicht tausend Designer dran gearbeitet.
Apple ist der erste Hersteller, der den G2-Standard unterstützt.
Ab 2024 werden alle großen Android-Smartphones folgen.
Das ist wirklich super, weil es bedeutet, dass das praktische MagSafe-Zubehör wie Powerbanks, Halterungen, Trinkflaschen und vieles mehr mit MagSafe dann von allen benutzt werden können.
Fazit, ich habe viel Spaß mit dem iPhone 15 Pro.
Und das liegt nicht an einer neuen Funktion, sondern an vielen kleinen Dingen, die zusammen einen großen Unterschied machen.
Das Design, USB-C, der Action-Knopf und auch die Tatsache, dass das Ganze immer noch in zwei Größen existiert.
Das mit dem Action-Knopf finde ich tatsächlich ganz cool.
Große Kritikpunkte habe ich eigentlich nicht. Das sind mehr so kleine Dinge, die nerven.
Wie zum Beispiel, dass die Kameras immer noch wahnsinnig weit rausstehen, die Nahenstellgrenze aber trotzdem echt schlecht ist.
Und dass diese Telekamera leider nur im Pro Max erhältlich ist.
Außerdem hatte ich darauf gehofft, dass es schnell laden gehen würde.
Ich auch nicht, Christian. Nicht großartig.
Oder dass der Asus zum Beispiel die Akkulaufzeit deutlich verbessern würde. Beides ist nicht eingetreten.
Der Preis ist dieses Jahr eher eine gute Nachricht, denn er ist gesunken um 100 bzw. 100.000 Euro.
Ja, kostet immer noch 1.500 Euro oder sowas.
Damit ist es zwar immer noch nicht günstig, im Gegenteil, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sich beim iPhone 16 Pro viel tun wird.
Und deswegen ist dieses Jahr ein guter Zeitpunkt, um zuzuschlagen, wenn man ein iPhone möchte.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, was es kostet.
Nein, das ist falsch. Das ist das normale 15er.
15 Pro! Ja, 1.500 Euro, sag ich doch.
Das ist halt übelst teuer.
Irgendwann reicht es nicht mehr, deine Niere zu verkaufen.
Ne, das gucken wir jetzt bestimmt nicht.
Das ist schon ein echt krasser Preis.
Es ist ein bisschen wie mit Grafikkartenpreisen.
Wenn ich das vergleiche zu früher für eine High-End Grafikkarte, das ist auch übertrieben gestiegen die letzten Jahre.
Gut, jetzt ist es wieder ein bisschen gefallen, weil es zwischenzeitlich ja echt absolut pervers teuer war.
Aber wenn ich mir überlege, die allererste Grafikkarte, ich weiß, jetzt kommt wieder so eine Geschichte, Boomer, Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg.
Ja, aber die allererste Grafikkarte, die ich mir selbst gekauft habe, war eine Elsa E-Razer 2.
Das war eine TNT 1, eine Riva TNT Karte.
Das war damals der High-End Shit schlechthin.
Und ich glaube, die hat damals, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Mark oder Euro war schon, 1999, das war noch Mark.
Die hat damals, glaube ich, 250 Mark oder so gekostet.
Lass es 250 Euro gewesen sein, ist auch egal.
So, und heute kannst, sag mal so, während Corona und danach konntest du ja quasi eine Null dranhängen für eine aktuelle Grafikkarte.
Eine aktuelle Grafikkarte, High-End Grafikkarte.
Aber mittlerweile sind wir auch noch bei so 1300 Euro oder sowas.
Was kostet denn eine 40,90 gerade?
Alter, ist immer noch mega teuer.
Ist schon ordentlich, ey, das kannst du nicht sagen.
Preislich geht das schon gut ab.
Krasses Ding.
Aber, gut.
Was kostet, warte mal.
Moment, Moment.
Chatge, Ausrufezeichen, PC.
Mal gucken, was meine aktuell kostet.
Ah, ein Schnapper.
Bei Berserker 1806.
Ja, da wollte ich schon immer was kaufen, ihr auch?
Berserker 1806.
Vertrauenswürdigster Shopname ever.
Ah, danach gibt es mein Factory 50 Euro mehr.
Zum Angebot.
Guck mal, jetzt kommt Berserker.
Was hat er so für Bewertungen?
Konnte man sich hier, ja.
Ach, das ist Shop Paradise 24.
Hä?
Zeigt Geizhals irgendein Blödsinn an?
Ist schon teuer.
Zumindest, so viel hast du, wie gesagt, also.
Das war meine aller allererste Grafikkarte.
Überlegt euch mal.
Ist irgendwie 250 Mark.
Lass es 250 Euro sein.
Zu, ähm.
Zu, ja, 1700.
Selbst mit Inflation ist das nicht zu erklären.
Das war damals echt High End.
Und die gab es sogar passiv gekühlt.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Die konnten damals High End Grafikkarten passiv gekühlt herstellen.
Das war übrigens noch vor DVI.
Oder HDMI.
Oder Display Port.
VGA Output.
Aber, man konnte damals, richtig nice.
Half-Life 1.
1600 x 1200 auf einem Röhrenmonitor spielen.
Flüssig.
Ich meine wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht irgendwie mit 200 FPS.
Oder sonst was.
Aber, aber flüssig.
Und es sah nice aus für die Damen.
Nein, nein, nein.
1600 x 1200.
X63P.
Hast du schon das Video von...
Moment, welches?
Ist ja nicht so als hätten die nur ein Video.
Weißt du wie viel dein PC im Idle verbraucht?
Ja, weiß ich.
Aber nicht aus dem Kopf.
Wir haben das gemessen im Stream.
Ich weiß nicht mal was es war.
Chat, ihr seid doch so schlau.
High IQ mäßig unterwegs.
Kann sich jemand noch dran erinnern?
Was der PC Idle verbraucht hat?
Ich weiß es beim besten Willen nicht mehr.
Es war aber nicht viel.
Nee, als wir den zusammengebaut haben.
Es war nicht viel.
Nein, nein, nein.
Es war weit unter 100 Watt.
Es war nicht viel.
Die Dinger sind Idle.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwie sowas würde ich sagen.
Die Dinger sind Idle recht sparsam.
Ja, genau.
Es war ziemlich wenig.
Es war auch weniger als ich gedacht habe.
Die Dinger sind tatsächlich relativ sparsam,
wenn sie Idle sind.
Aber wenn sie unter Last sind,
verbrauchen die extrem viel.
Quatsch, 5 Watt war es nicht.
Nein, es war schon mehr.
Also,
voll Last hat das Ding...
Weiß ich.
Ich glaube 550 Watt
oder irgendwie sowas mal gezogen.
Ja, guck mal.
Damals konnte man auf den Grafikkarten
den Speicher und so noch,
ich vermute mal, dass das Speicher war hier,
noch erkennen.
Und ich war damals mega beeindruckt,
weil es gab damals ein Artikel in der GameStar.
Da stand,
dass auf der Größe eines
Pfennigstücks
in diesem Topmodell
50 Millionen Transistoren
verbaut sind.
Leute, Größe von einem
Pfennigstück und 50 Millionen Transistoren,
da lacht sich heute jeder CPU kaputt.
Das ist so...
Das ist so groß,
dass du es unter dem Mikroskop fast noch siehst.
So klein,
dass du es fast noch siehst.
Heute ist das so klein.
Ich weiß nicht, was du auf einer Fläche
von so einem Daumennagel hast heute an Transistoren,
aber ich glaube, das sind deutlich mehr.
Ich weiß nicht wie viel mehr,
aber es sind deutlich mehr.
Naja, zumindest das war meine erste Grafikkarte,
die ich mir selbst gekauft habe.
Ich weiß,
ich habe jetzt komplett verdrängt,
was ich eigentlich raus... Achso, ja, Preis, Preisentwicklung.
Ja, genau.
Und da haben sich die Preise halt krass entwickelt
und bei Smartphones auch.
Ich meine, wenn ich das mal vergleiche,
mit...
Beispielsweise,
ich hatte ja früher so ein dickes Nokia-Klopper.
Der hat auch nur...
Der hat auch nur ein Apollonai gekostet
versus ein aktuelles iPhone.
Wobei man das halt nicht...
Der Vergleich ist tatsächlich ein bisschen unfair.
So ein aktuelles Smartphone hat natürlich auch
deutlich mehr Funktionen, deutlich mehr Technik
und es ist ein ganz anderes Gerät.
Das kannst du nicht vergleichen.
Du kannst kein aktuelles Smartphone vergleichen
mit so einem fetten Nokia-Klopper.
Zusammenbauen HN-PCR.
Okay.
Und da sieht man jetzt irgendwie...
Das ist die Temperatur.
Und wo sieht man...
Habe ich nicht irgendwo ein Bild gehabt?
Von so einem Power-Meter?
Ich hatte doch
da so ein Ding angeschlossen.
Oder vielleicht sage ich es einfach nur.
Oh, da habe ich ein bisschen gestruggelt,
das reinzukriegen.
Zumal ich keinen Platz hatte hier.
Ich habe hier oben drüber das Ring-Light gehabt
und ich habe kaum was gesehen.
Das war ganz grausam.
Ach ja, Leute.
Und die Haarrisse im Mainboard,
die war natürlich ganz kritisch.
Ich habe das hier irgendwann einge...
Wobei ich habe es noch gar nicht...
Hier hatte ich es gar nicht ins Gehäuse gebaut.
Hier hatte ich es einfach nur angeschlossen.
Und da war die Grafikkarte
auch noch gar nicht dran.
Als ich das ins Gehäuse eingebaut habe,
haben die Leute die ganze Zeit erzählt,
Max, wenn du die Grafikkarte so einbaust,
dann bekommst du Haarrisse im Mainboard.
Ja, also Smartphone-technisch
tut sich die letzten Jahre
tatsächlich recht wenig.
Das stimmt schon.
Oh, ein cute Discord-Icon.
Da haben wir drauf gewartet, oder?
Weil ich habe Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich weiß, ich habe die letzten Tage
ein bisschen wenig Stream-Soar gemacht.
Aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich hatte beispielsweise gestern...
Ey, Progst,
dafür 1 Million Potatoes.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gestern
den ganzen Tag Wartungsarbeiten
auf der Arbeit gemacht, wobei das relativ
entspannte Wartungsarbeiten waren.
Ich musste legit irgendwie
drei Befehle ausführen den ganzen Tag über.
Aber es war halt trotzdem immer wieder
ein bisschen schwierig.
Wie funktioniert deine Wortsuche?
Gibt es da eine KI für?
Ja, ja.
KI ist vielleicht ein bisschen
zu viel gesagt, aber ja, gibt es.
Zwar
alle Worts
archivdurchsuchen.
Du kannst hier beispielsweise nach Keckel suchen.
Und der hat so ein Transkript
von dem, was ich sage,
in der Volltextsuche
drin.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie es genau
funktioniert aktuell, wobei der Max hat es ja schon
geschrieben.
Open AI Whisper
und dann in Volltextsuche rein.
Also
initial hatten wir in der Cloud
Grafikkarten-Server
gemietet, also Server mit GPU.
Max, weißt du noch, was wir da gemietet
haben für initiale
Index beziehungsweise initiale
Transkripterstellung
zu machen? Ich glaube, wir hatten
eine Kiste gemietet mit
3080, mit
zwei 3080 Grafikkarten drin oder
sowas. Oh, war
das schon eine 4090?
Nee, oder? Wir haben das doch schon länger.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Es lief
zumindest
zwei Wochen,
bis das indiziert war
oder halt
integriert war. Weiß ich nicht.
Nee.
Wie sieht das bei mir aus?
Habe ich noch meine
WOTs? Oh nein!
TempEmail leaked.
Ähm.
Ich habe doch alles noch drin.
Ja, wenn die TOS Musik
verwenden, dann kann das sein.
Aber dafür gibt es ja mittlerweile
die Möglichkeit, dass du im WOT eine
andere Musikspur nimmst als im
geschrieben. Vielleicht sind die aber auch so
faul wie ich und machen das nicht.
Managed MongoDB Hosting Provider
empfiehlt. Nein, habe ich gar
keine Erfahrung mit. Muss es
Managed MongoDB sein oder willst du einfach nur eine
gescheit funktionierende NoSQL
Datenbank? Weil da haben die ganzen
Cloud-Anbieter ihre eigenen Dinger.
Aber
Managed MongoDB, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher,
ob
Google sowas zum Beispiel
gar nicht, ob die sowas haben.
Also weiß ich nicht, kenne ich nicht.
Ich habe auch mit
MongoDB so gut wie nichts zu tun.
Ach guck mal, hier gibt es sogar ein Screenshot von der Indexierung.
Also
PyTorch
So, also
das, da hatten wir eine
Kiste mit
Wo sieht
man das? Sieht man da
was das für eine Grafik? Ah hier, hier, die Grafik
Also das war eine 3090
war es, ne? 3090
Die hat gekostet
36 Cent pro Stunde
Und wir hatten es
eineinhalb Wochen laufen. Oben links
Ah hier
RTX 3090
RunPod
Wusste gar nicht, dass wir da irgendwas
Da wo es ging
Das ist jetzt übrigens
ein richtig gutes Beispiel
warum sich
Cloud
Warum sich Cloudinfrastruktur lohnen kann
Überlegt euch mal
Ihr habt jetzt die Auswahl
Ihr stellt euch
Ihr kauft, also ihr habt jetzt
den Anwendungsfall
Also ein Beispiel dafür, warum sich Cloudinfrastruktur
richtig lohnen kann
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt den Anwendungsfall
Ihr habt ganz viel Videomaterial und ihr wollt
per AI
ein Transkript von erstellen
Also quasi Textformen dessen, was gesagt wurde
in dem Video
Und ihr kauft euch selbst
eine Kiste mit
32 GB RAM, 16 CPUs
und einer 3090
Da seid ihr für eine ordentliche
Kiste doch schon ein paar tausend
Euro los
Ihr könnt jetzt allerdings auch hergehen
und euch sowas in der Cloud mieten
Dann bezahlt ihr 36 Cent
die Stunde und je nachdem wie lang
ihr braucht
Achja und ihr bezahlt auch keine Stromkosten, die sind dabei
Je nachdem wie lang ihr braucht
Und lohnt sich das
richtig
preismäßig
Von mehreren tausend Euro zu ein paar hundert Euro
Könnt ihr mal ausrechnen
was das gekostet hat
36 Cent die Stunde
sind am Tag 8 Euro
So
8 Euro mal, wie lang hast du gesagt
Max, eineinhalb Wochen, mach mal 14 Tage
Mach mal 14 Tage
120 Euro, so
Haben wir 120 Euro bezahlt versus paar tausend
Euro für eigene Kiste
hinstellen und zusammenbauen und hinstellen
Kacke, also da lohnt sich
Cloud Infrastruktur, ich hab auch noch einen anderen
Anwendungszweck
Und wenn man richtig gesehen hat, dass es wirklich was bringt
Ich musste mal OpenStreetView
Maps
preprocessen für Routenplanung
Und dafür
haben wir ne, glaub 48
Ne, 32
Kerne, oder ne 24
Kerne, 128
Gig, ne,
Kerne, 96 Gig
Vm haben wir damals bei Hetzner genommen
Und haben das
preprocessen lassen
Innerhalb von, weiß nicht,
2 Stunden
Dann hab ich am Ende
3,50 Euro bezahlt oder so
Hat das Transkript
in Deutsch ohne Probleme funktioniert
Ja
Und da lohnt sich das halt mega für sowas
Wenn man solche Infrastruktur wirklich
24-7 laufen lassen will
für Monate und Jahre
Dann kann man sich überlegen, das wird schon ganz schön teuer
Aber wenn man mal so kurze Burst
Power braucht, da ist Cloud Infra
Das ist ein Anwendungsgebiet
zumindest, wo sich Cloud Infrastruktur
richtig lohnt und auch ein Anwendungsgebiet
wo Cloud Infrastruktur deutlich
deutlich billiger sein kann
als eigene Hardware
In vielen Fällen ist Cloud Infrastruktur nicht billiger
als das selbst zu machen, oder generell
Aber da massive viel billiger
Okay Leute
Ich geh jetzt was essen
Wir sehen uns vielleicht
zur Mittag nochmal, mal gucken
Wir müssen ja nochmal ein bisschen Technikkrams uns mal wieder anschauen
Mir riecht Spock heute
Was machen wir denn heute?
Oh Mann, ne, ne, Javascript, please, please
Kein Kegg Javascript heute
Kein Kegg Javascript
Please, das halte ich heute nicht aus
Mal gucken
Alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns, bis dann
Ich hab Hunger, see you, machts gut